So Leute, heute ist offizieller Jebaited-Tag.
Deswegen Jebaite ich euch jetzt. Ich mache jetzt gleich Face Reveal.
Lul, Jebaited.
Hallo Leko, Dankeschön, 8 Monate. Massive Sub.
Jebaited Reveal. So lange es nicht dick Reveal ist.
Es wird nichts Revealed hier.
Ich habe den Titel nicht geändert. Ich bin ein bisschen müde.
Irgendwie ein bisschen AFK.
Ich werde mal versuchen, dass wir mit der Geschichte vorletztens weiter machen.
Hast du das von Linux? Nein, ich gucke mir aus Prinzip keine Jebaited-Videos an.
Golem hat heute Morgen irgendwas geschrieben, dass Bill Gates ein Mini-Atomkraftwerk hat.
Mittlerweile ist es nicht einfach nur, wenn man eine gute Idee hat, sondern einfach nur komplett Pflicht, dass jedes Magazin ein Jebaited-Artikel veröffentlicht.
Hat doch jeder schon die Spiegelung in den letzten Streams gesehen? Naja, überall. Spiegelstells.
Tatsächlich Stripes, das stimmt. Ja, wir machen heute weiter. Hast du das mit... mit was?
Mit Kui? Wer ist Kui?
Any Cuties oder was soll das heißen?
Nee, ich habe keine Ahnung, was das sein soll.
Warum sollte ich das jetzt einfach aufmachen?
Achso, nee, was ist das?
Ach, ist mir... Weiß nicht.
Okay, ich klick das jetzt an. Okay, war es Kui.
Cleaning-Stelle urberechtigt im Internet. Ist ein Unappetitiv wurde von...
Ja, und? Ist das Jebaited oder ist das echt? Ich habe keine Ahnung.
Wie machst du Backups von deinem Liedungssorfer? Aktuell, also normalerweise verwende ich Borg-Backup.
Das ist tatsächlich... What the fuck?
Das ist tatsächlich ganz nice. Aber aktuell mache ich easy as fuck einfach nächtliches R-Sync auf eine externe Platte.
Okay, ich habe keine Ahnung. Also, wie gesagt, ich habe keine Ahnung, was das ist.
Tipps und du mein Schminktipps? Du musst mal unbedingt zu ihm in Chat und ihn fragen, wie es mit Schminktipps aussieht.
Ist das Englisch da? Nee, wir können ihn gar nicht fragen.
Rude! Danke schön für den Prime-Subscription.
Oder ist es Englisch? Raude. So wie Rauter.
DSP-DNS-Nutz ist richtig pains, Champ. Ey, wer das macht...
Gut, wenn das klar illegale Seiten sind, dann gibt es ja dazu auch irgendeinen Urteil oder irgendeine Einstellung.
Ja, keine Ahnung, müssen wir mal angucken. Aber wir sollen alle mal ihren Kram geschissen bekommen und das machen, wofür sie bezahlt werden, nämlich Provider sein.
Und kein Block-Hider. Okay, das war jetzt ein schlechter Witz, aber ihr müsst euch weinen.
Das Stripes ist wieder hier on fire.
Habt ihr schon gesehen, wenn ihr Sputnik auf Twitter folgt, dann dürft ihr die ersten sein, die sich Corona impfen lassen.
Hier, guckt mal da. Wenn wir den followen, dann dürfen wir uns als erstes in Russland impfen lassen.
Warum ist das eigentlich White Seam? Geh weg, Flashbang. Ich finde, das wirkt äußerst vertrauenserweckend, wenn man Impfstoffe und Social Media hat, wo man sich nur durch Follows impfen lassen darf.
Oh nein, die Trends. Ich darf mir die Trends in Twitter nicht angucken. Ich bin da immer gleich getriggert. Ich klicke da nicht drauf. Max, du darfst da nicht drauf klicken, da auch nicht.
Okay, das obere kann man vielleicht noch anklicken. Aber die anderen Trends, dass ich ertrag die Dummheit der Leute auf Twitter, aber generell der Menschheit nicht. Ich halte das nicht aus.
Ich muss das ignorieren.
Kann mir jemand mal, wo wir gerade bei Dummheit sind, vielleicht kann mir das jemand erklären. Sag mal Leute, hat Twitter eine neue Schrift für die, ich habe für sowas, ich mache Auge gerade, wie man so schön sagt heute, ich habe für sowas ein Auge.
Twitch hat die Schrift geändert bei Useranzeigenzahlen. Moment, FFZ hat die Schrift geändert. Hier sieht es noch okay aus.
Oder ist das hier auch eine andere? Nee, die sieht anders aus. Die Zahlen sind, guck mal, die Zahlen sind breiter, seht ihr das? 118, die Zahlen sind weiter gespaced als sonst.
Kein Scheiß. Die Zahlen sind weiter gespaced, habt ihr das gesehen? Guckt, die Zahlen sind weiter gespaced.
Alter, was sind das für Klassenbenamungen? Fällt euch das auch auf? Ja, das ist vielleicht FFZ. Die Zuschauerzahlen sind weiter gespaced.
Und das sieht fast so aus, als ist zwischen den ersten beiden Pixel mehr, aber das wird wahrscheinlich nicht so sein. Aber das ist anders als sonst. Ich sag's euch. Exzellent.
Genau, das ist das Archiv, ne? Ich hab schon Auge gemacht, das sieht anders aus. Projektskrim, Twitter, Trendsblocker. Das musst du gar nicht blocken, du musst einfach dein Land auf Andorra umstellen.
Dann hast du keine Trends. Anscheinend sind die Andorianer, wie heißen Leute, die in Andorra wohnen, die sind nicht so Twitterfreudig, da gibt's nie Trends.
Ja, die gehen mir auch mega auf den Sack. Die überall lustig sind. Die sonst nie lustig sind. Wisst ihr, Leute, die diese ultra-krasse April-Jokes machen, das sind auch die gleichen Leute, die das ganze Jahr einfach nicht lachen und bei Fasching dann übelst lustig sind.
Bin ich da, bin ich fest davon überzeugt. Change my Mind-Chat. Ja, exzellent ist das hier, exzellent.
Ja, aber ich glaub, da musst du doch nicht eingeloggt sein. Also, YouTube geht ohne eingeloggt zu sein, aber Twitter, weiß ich nicht, ob Twitter-Settings gehen die ohne? Dark? Wo stellt man Twitter um? Ohne eingeloggt zu sein? Geht nicht, oder? Kein Dark-Theme ohne eingeloggt zu sein.
Unten, der Twitter hat unten kein Futter. Twitter ist ja Endschluss-Scroll, das ist ja auch so die Pest von modernen Websiten, dass du nicht runterscrollen kannst.
Nee, ach, wir lassen einfach das Dark-Theme an. Ich mach mal meinen Channel auf. So, da können wir ein bisschen Werbung machen. Also, Leute, followt alle Sputnik. Nur wenn ihr auf Twitter folgt, dann könnt ihr euch impfen lassen. Exzellent.
Übrigens, ihr werdet es nicht glauben, DHL Express kam und hat es geliefert aus den USA. Ist die Musiklautstärke okay? Ich glaube, ich kann einen Ticken leiser noch machen, oder?
Wobei, passt eigentlich, passt eigentlich, passt eigentlich. Ich bin heute relativ laut. Ah, wisst ihr, warum ich so laut bin? Weil mich Teams Twitter jebaitet. Teams jebaitet mich wieder.
Stimmt überhaupt nicht. Über Steuerungsstells ist angesagt. Jetzt, jetzt ist gut. Jetzt. Exzellent. ASMR-Stream. So, so ist gut. So, also, auf geht's. Twitter Dark Mode.
Halt mal her. Teams und Zooms größer. Das hat man doch nur, wenn man eingeloggt ist.
Ja, gut. Also, Chet, wir machen heute weiter mit der gleichen Geschichte vom letzten Mal. Bloß, dass ich ein paar Probleme festgestellt habe. Das, was wir gemacht haben, klappt nicht so ganz. Weil die Library zu Pepofet ist, die wir verwenden.
So, für alle, die nicht dabei waren, ich werde das noch mal kurz erklären, um was es geht. Ich habe die VM schon gest...
Ich habe die VM ausgewesen. Was ist denn da los? Lull. Ja, richtig Pepofet, Tommy. Ist es ein Baum oder ist es ein Elefant?
Vielleicht ist es ja auch ein Baumofant. PaintsChamp. Joke, ich weiß.
So, also. Firefox. Leaked. Guck, der leaked sich auch. Der macht gerade Face Reveal. Der ist kurz vorm Face Reveal, der Elefant.
Warum habe ich so viel AliExpress eigentlich offen? Ein Baum mit Rüssel, genau. Ein dickes Reveal.
Wobei, es heißt ja Tail in dem Fall. So, Code. Die Codera ist am Start, Leute. Die Codera.
So, if you enjoy. Nope. Nope. Ich enjoye nix. Das sagen die Leute auch immer in den Videos. Ich sehe immer alles so negativ. Ich kann. Ich enjoye nix.
Ich bin zu alt, um zu enjoyen. Und umfragen mache ich schon mal gar nichts.
Ich enjoye nur Cute Twitch Chat. Was du mit dem ESP machst, gibt es glaube ich schon fertig.
Aber ESP Home. Sackt. Gefällt mir nicht. Ich will den Gramm selbst programmieren und kein komisches Jammel Zeug machen.
Und wenn ich Custom Logik brauche, weil ich brauche immer Custom Logik, dann irgendwie C++ Inline den Jammel machen. Das ist ja mal absolut der Witz.
Also, das mache ich nicht. Ich habe das ausprobiert. Ich fand das eigentlich ganz cool. Aber das war mir dann im Endeffekt nix.
Nee, das haben mir nicht gefallen.
Ja, und was auch ESP Home nicht kann, ist den Batteriestand. Den werden wir heute noch abfragen.
Hey Max und Chat. Der Chat ist am Start. Exzellent Chat. Hey Max und Chat. Ich wurde heute für ein Vorstellungsgespräch eingeladen.
Ich soll den Termin per E-Mail bestätigen. Wie formuliere ich das am besten? Einfach passt. So was hier.
Kannst du auch schreiben, dass du dich drauf freust oder so? Vielleicht.
Denk dir irgendwas in der Richtung aus. Aber das ist doch... Ja.
Du kannst ruhig viel Dank für die Einladung schreiben, dass du dich drauf freust.
Termin bestätigt. Also viel mehr muss man da ja nicht großartig schreiben.
Hast du das schon mitbekommen mit der Aus... Ist das das Video von dem Anwalt? Ja, das haben wir schon mal geguckt.
Ja, die haben totalen Dachschaden. Wirklich. Die drehen voll am Rad.
Ja, aber schon richtig.
Und dann auch noch so unlustig. Ich weiß, ich weiß. Ich bin irgendwie ein bisschen müde. Mal gucken, wie weit wir kommen.
Aber heute ist ja Gebate-Attack. Da kann man mal auch versuchen lustig zu sein.
So, jetzt mal kurz Hacker-Modus aktivieren. Ich hoffe, ihr seid auch schon drin, Chat.
Dann können wir gleich anfangen.
Vielleicht machen wir heute auch noch die Waage, wenn das gut klappt.
Weil, wie gesagt, also ich werde das mal bevor wir anfangen. Ich erkläre mal, was ich machen will.
Oder ich erkläre mal, was wir schon angefangen haben. Und zwar...
Ich habe so ein paar Sensoren hiervon. Flashbang.
Ich habe so ein paar Sensoren hier. Das sind eigentlich Sensoren.
Die sind jetzt auf einmal schwarz. Warum sind die jetzt auf einmal schwarz?
Die ganze Zeit waren die weiß oder grün. Jetzt sind die schwarz.
Grasblumen-Monitor. Darkseam.
Okay, das hat kein Bluetooth. Was hat das denn dann?
Was hat das denn dann, wenn das nicht über...
Der Alte, da erzähle ich gleich was zu.
Über was geht das? Überblick?
Steht nicht da?
Besser.
Hier, was ist es denn jetzt?
Okay, also das ist kein Wi-Fi-Support. Das ist okay. Aber ist es... Also, okay.
Wenn es kein Wi-Fi ist und wenn es kein Bluetooth ist, dann ist die große Frage...
Was für China-Gramm ist es denn dann?
Was, ZigBee meinste?
Wie wäre es, das da hinzuschreiben?
Was, nur eine LED? Wie soll denn das mit der LED funktionieren?
Die zeigt der überhaupt... Ach so, meint die... Nee.
Was macht das?
Das sieht ästlich aus.
Ach, kann das sein, dass das nur Wasser standmacht?
Nee, ich habe keinen Plastenschimmer, echt nicht.
Nein, die LED ist oben drauf, ich habe so einen Teil. Ja, aber wie überträgt man die Daten?
Das da oben ist keine LED zum Statusanzeigen, das ist der Helligkeitssensor.
Die haben alle.
Aber wie überträgt das Ding?
Die sagen ja auch, es hat keinen Bluetooth, haben die irgendwo hier geschrieben.
Und wird das Ding mit einer Knopfzelle betrieben für mehr Müll?
Okay, keine Ahnung, das kaufe ich nicht, so ein Crap passt keine Ahnung.
Zumindest, also ich erkläre euch mal, was ich vorhabe. Ach so, ich wollte erst mal was anderes erzählen, und zwar...
Die LED ist keine LED, das ist ein Sensor fürs Licht.
Also, ich wollte ja noch hierzu was sagen, genau.
Hast du dich eigentlich beim Vorstellungsgespräch auch wie ein Bänker angezogen, oder wie bist du hier? Nee, habe ich nicht.
Also, ich habe ja meine Ausbildung nicht bei der Bank gemacht, wo ich jetzt arbeite,
sondern bei einem damaligen, würde ich sagen, recht mittelständischen Internetprovider,
oder Provider, der hat alles Mögliche gemacht von Internet und Hosting und sonstige Geschichten.
Und hat auch ein paar Debian-Pakete maintained und solche Geschichten, also die haben alles Mögliche gemacht.
Und da war nichts viel mit Anzug.
Aber, was witzig war, dort wo ich beim Vorstellungsgespräch war,
wir mussten erstmal so einen komischen Test machen,
die haben uns den Test vorgesetzt für normale Ausgelernte.
Das war eigentlich schon fies, da wollten die mit Cisco-Befehle und IP-Tables und Wim-Schnickschnack und so wissen.
Und wir haben erst ein Vorstellungsgespräch, also wir haben erst den Test gemacht,
und danach so ein kurzes Vorstellungsgespräch.
Und es war so ein Typ dabei, also es waren da an dem Tag, wo ich mich jetzt noch dran erinnern kann,
zwei Typen, ein Mädel für die BWL-Zeug, die wollte da irgendwie Bürokaufmann oder so lernen, keine Ahnung.
Sorry, sorry, jetzt habe ich mich versprochen, natürlich Bürokaufmann, wie gendert man denn,
weil wir das gerade auf Twitter gelesen haben, wie gendert man Bürokaufmann richtig?
Büroverkauffach, nein, nein, nein, Bürokaufrau geht ja auch nicht, es muss ja was Neutrales geben.
Bürokaufinnen, Moment, das muss, da muss noch irgendwas, sieht man schon, wie verrückt der ganze Kram ist.
Sieht man schon, wie verrückt das ist, das funktioniert überhaupt nicht.
Bürokauf, Bürofachangestelltinnen oder sowas vielleicht.
Fachkraft, Fachkraftinnen für Bürokommunikation vielleicht.
Das sind die Probleme, die wir 2021 zu lösen haben.
Zumindest ein Typ, der bei meinem Vorstellungsgespräch war, oder da, wo wir den Test gemacht haben, der war super over-dressed,
also da kam der echt so im Anzug an und so was, und ich gehe mal davon aus, dem hat die Mutter erzählt,
oder die Eltern, du musst da mit dem Anzug hin, sonst macht sich das, sonst, weißt du, sonst, ja, sonst kommt es nicht gut an oder so.
Und der Typ, der war so krass nervös, der hat quasi schon im Flur gesessen und geschwitzt,
vom einfach nur dasitzen und gezittert und so, der war voll, der war vollkommen neben der Spur.
Zumindest, wir haben den Test gemacht und danach kam, das habe ich glaube ich schon mal erzählt hier,
und das war keine Absicht, muss ich dazu sagen, ist mir erst im Nachhinein eingefallen, wie fies das war,
und danach hatten wir Vorstellungsgespräch, dann haben die gesagt, so, wartet mal kurz, eine Viertelstunde, wir melden uns gleich,
und also ist einer rausgekommen und hat gemeint, so, ja, wir sind fertig, wer will denn zuerst,
und habe ich mich so umgeguckt, die wollten alle nicht, habe ich gesagt, okay, komme ich mit, mache ich zuerst,
und da war ich dran, war ich drin, und ich habe übeles Glück gehabt, ich habe mich ja null um so rhetorische,
ich habe mir da keine rhetorischen Tricks vorher überlegt oder so fürs Vorstellungsgespräch,
ich habe mir nichts angeguckt und sonst was, ich hätte auch genauso gut ins Klo greifen können, aber ich hatte das Glück gehabt,
und bin ich rein mit, also wie gesagt für meine Ausbildung, da bin ich mit rein,
und ich habe halt gleich am Anfang gesagt, noch halb bevor ich mich hingesetzt habe, die Frage mit IP-Tables war aber fies,
und da wollten die wissen, ja, warum, wie kommen sie da drauf, und ich habe gesagt, ja, ich wusste das,
und dann habe ich das eben noch mal aufgezählt, so nachdem, und ich wusste das, das, das und das, aber genau die, die sie gefragt haben, wusste ich nicht,
also in der Richtung war das, ich bin mir nicht mehr hundertprozentig sicher, wie genau da Wortlaut war,
und da hattest du schon super Einstieg, und da haben wir irgendwie eine Viertelstunde über IP-Tables und Linux-Sachen gequatscht,
und sie wollten unter anderem von mir auch wissen, wie das so mit dem Internet aussieht, wie man so ins Internet,
die Frage hat er damals doof gestellt, er hat gefragt, und wie kommen sie so ins Internet,
und ich, und ich dachte, der will von mir wissen, wie es auf Provider-Seite aussieht, da habe ich eben das ein bisschen aufgezählt,
und dann meinte er, nee, nee, das weiß ich selbst, wie sieht es denn bei Ihnen daheim aus, und ich so, ja, so und so,
naja, zumindest war ich dann fertig, bin dann rausgegangen, habe noch aus Versehen einen Stift in der Hand gehabt,
da habe ich gerade für den Trügich jetzt einen Stift in der Hand, und dann hat der Typ gesagt, ah, lass, lass, lass, nehm mit, nehm mit,
also, ja, von der Firma, so, und ich bin dann rausgegangen, und da saßen die anderen beiden noch auf der Bank und haben gewartet,
und der Typ, der, ey, der war schon durchgeschwitzt, ne, und da bin ich dann auch vorbei,
und hab gesagt, hier Jungs, macht gut, vielleicht sieht man sich wieder, aber, ey, alter, was die da wissen wollen,
oder was die für Fragen stellen, habe ich dann so aus Spaß gesagt, ne, so dachte ich mir, ja, passt auf, ey, alter, was die für Fragen stellen,
es war eigentlich eher so ein Joke, und der Typ, der eh schon übelst geschwitzt hat, der ist fast vor dem Stuhl gefallen,
der ist quasi wortwörtlich, also der ist bildlich Monarch Est in sich zusammen,
und es war keine Absicht, ich schwörs euch, Leute, ich schwörs euch, das war keine Absicht,
mir ist erst im Nachhinein klar geworden, dass der Typ, glaube ich, dadurch, ich hab dem den Rest gegeben,
der war fertig danach mit der Welt, ich würd mir echt interessieren, wie das Vorstellungsgespräch von dem gelaufen ist,
er ist von der Konkurrenz ausgeknipst, ja,
er ist von der Konkurrenz ausgeknipst, ja, okay, ja, ist excellent simply delivered,
express von 1-2 Tage auf 14 Tage, am Ende ist es angekommen, ja,
ich frag mich übrigens, wie die das jetzt machen, bei mir auf der aktuellen Arbeit, frage ich mich echt,
die sind nicht so pleading edge, was Bewerbungs-, also gerade die Personalabteilung,
was Bewerbungsgespräche online und sowas angeht, bei uns ist das kein Problem,
aber gerade bei Azubis mit den Ausbildern und der Personalabteilung,
stelle ich mir das echt pains-champig vor, mit denen Bewerbungsgespräche führen zu müssen,
08max07, Dankeschön für den Sub, 6 Monate, massive Subscription, sorry, falls ich irgendwas übersehen hab,
Leute, ich war gerade so, so am erzählen, aber ich hoffe, es gefällt euch trotzdem, schön, dass ihr da seid,
hier hab ich es doch, thomascool110 hab ich übersehen, 10 Monate, massive Subscriptions,
das ist ja doppel plus IQ hier heute,
ja, das ist auch nicht so, aber trotzdem, das ist ja gerade der Witz dabei,
die stellen keine wirklich inhaltlichen Fragen, aber aus irgendwelchen Gründen,
musst du dich trotzdem mit denen auseinandersetzen, ja, also, musst du durch,
kommt dir auch später ab und zu mal vor, dass du sinnlose Sachen gefragt wirst,
die, äh, wo du nicht so genau weißt, was du da eigentlich sagen sollst, ne,
äh, also wenn du das meinst, was vorhin einer gepostet hat, ja, dann umgeht das, das,
DNS-Filter, am besten ist, du benutzt auch noch einen verschlüsselten DNS,
oder DNS über HTTPS oder so, da kann keiner mehr rein funken, wie gesagt,
die sollen alle mal lieber mehr providern, anstatt zu block-hidern, äh,
ja, manche übertreiben es auch total, also, ich hab jetzt schon ein paar Mal gelesen,
wie gesagt, eigene Erfahrungen hab ich damit nicht, äh, dass immer mehr Firmen in Deutschland,
letztens hat sich einer beschwert, dass ich Firmen-Sachen nicht unternehme, er hat Recht,
ja, aber irgendwie hab ich mir das so angewöhnt, ich weiß auch nicht, eigentlich ist das nicht richtig,
aber dazu kann ich bloß sagen,
dass jetzt immer mehr so die Praxis hier Einzug erhält, dass man so Ami-Style-Einstellungstests macht,
was sagst du zu Kui? Wurde ich heut schon gefragt, hat mir nichts gesagt,
bis, ich hab das erst von April Schatz gehalten, hat mir nichts gesagt, muss ich mir, muss ich mir echt mal,
ok, wir gucken uns das jetzt an zusammen, wir gucken uns das jetzt an, aber erst noch mal hier dazu was,
also ich hab jetzt schon öfters gelesen, dass jetzt auch hier in Deutschland öfters so diese Ami-Style-Einstellungstests-Einzug erhält,
also sprich so mit, mit, äh, was weiß ich, Invert-Binary-Tree oder so Dinger,
das Problem ist nur, dass das halt eben nicht Google, Facebook, Netflix, Microsoft oder Amazon ist,
sorry, Alphabet, das ist ja nicht mal Google, ist ja Alphabet,
und die halten sich glaube ich alle für deutlich zu wichtig mit solchen Einstellungstests,
was interessiert die 0815-Klitsche um die Ecke, ob einer irgendwie einen Binärbaum umdrehen kann,
die halten sich echt für zu wichtig, ja,
ok, also zeigst mal her, was, was ist das, über uns,
ok, die, wir gucken mal ob Heise, hat Heise was dazu geschrieben, Kui, Kui, ne, Kui,
zeig mal, Kui, das ist doch schon vom 15.3., das ist doch uralt,
ne, 20.3., 20.3., Kui, ok, zeig mal her,
die Clearing-Stelle Urheberrechte im Internet ist eine Urheber-Stelle, die wurde von Internetzugangsanbietern und Rechteinhabern ganz mal ehrlich,
ich bin der Meinung, dass Provider nicht zu sehr ins Bett gehen sollten mit Rechteinhabern und umgedreht,
das eine hat mit dem anderen noch erstmal gar nichts zu tun,
Provider sollten möglichst freien, offenen, zu allem möglichen Internetzugang anbieten,
außer sie werden dazu gesetzlich verpflichtet, eingeschränkt, wie auch immer,
dass Rechteinhaber dann natürlich scharf sind, drauf, das hat man ja schon lange gesehen,
ich erinnere mich nur noch zu Zeiten, wo, was gab es denn da, Napster, Audio Galaxy und alles mögliche am Start waren,
wo die immer noch rumgeschrieben, oh Leute, jeder Download ist eine CD weniger verkauft,
oh na, wir verkaufen so wenige CDs, die haben ja auch gedacht, sie sind morgen pleite, also haben sie so getan, ne,
oder diese Werbung, wo ist Papa, Papa ist im Knast, weil er Raub kopiert hat, alles dummes Zeug gewesen,
aber es ist insofern aus Sicht der Rechteinhaber noch halbwegs verständlich, sowas zu machen,
das als Provider noch mitmachen ist fraglich,
um noch objektive Kriterien prüfen zu können, ja, ja, ist klar, wenn Rechteinhaber mit dabei sind,
dann wird es bestimmt nach äußerst, äußerst objektiven Kriterien geprüft,
das wissen wir ja, die sind da garantiert äußerst neutral,
ein Prüfungsausschuss prüft auf Antrag der Rechteinhaber und empfiehlt bei Vorliegen der Verordnung,
der nennt sich strukturell, ey, wenn die das heute zum 1. April hochgeladen hätten, ja,
ja, ja, wer ist denn alles dabei, Marcel Davis persönlich,
Empfehlungen, ach Moment, ich dachte, man kann sich diesen Livestream angucken,
aber da gibt es eine, ach das ist, ja, haben die denn ein ordentliches Impressum,
so, was hat Semper Video, hat dazu ein Video gemacht, das können wir später gucken,
ich will jetzt erstmal ein bisschen basteln, sonst penne ich total ein,
Telekom und Vodafone haben jetzt Internetfehler, by the way, ihr sollt euch übrigens sagen,
die haben in der Vergangenheit immer gesagt, sie sind für freies Internet und blocken nicht,
und bla und hin und her, also gestern so, heute so, das juckt dir nicht,
die machen das, was Kohle bringt, das ist ja all die allgemeine Sache, in der Regel kannst
du dich eigentlich nur auf eine Sache verlassen, dass dort das gemacht wird, was Geld bringt,
und, oder was von, was auch noch eine Möglichkeit ist, was von eigenen Fehlern vielleicht ablenkt,
aber da kannst du dich, da kannst du dich, das gucken wir uns nach an, da kannst du dich
dann auf jeden Fall drauf verlassen, das ist eigentlich fast überall so,
also ich finde es auch witzig, wenn dann irgendwie einer, der in der Regierung sitzt, wieder
irgendwelche Diskussionen vom Zaun bricht, die nur nötig sind, weil er es die letzten
15 Jahre selbst verschissen hat, um davon abzulenken, aber die Leute, das hat man gelernt,
die Leute diskutieren heute unglaublich gerne, sind unglaublich gerne empört,
und das kann man ja auch gezielt ausnutzen, wenn man nicht will, dass die Leute drüber sprechen,
was man, dass man es verschissen hat, dann wirft man den Leuten halt irgend anderen Blödsinn
hin, über den sie sich wahnsinnig aufregen und diskutieren können, dann merkt keiner,
dass man es verschissen hat, das passiert ja auch an vielen Stellen, es wird über so unglaublich
viele unsinnige Sachen diskutiert, dass ja eigentlich kaum noch Platz ist, um über wichtige
Sachen zu diskutieren, oder zumindest breitflächig, ohne dass sofort die Diskussion unterbunden
wird mit irgendwelchen Totschlagargumenten, aber dass die da am Start sind, wundert mich
nicht, da fehlen noch ein paar, also da würde mich nicht wundern, wenn da noch ein paar
dazukommen in nächster Zeit. So, wir gucken uns nachher das Video von Semper Video an,
wir basteln jetzt erstmal ein bisschen weiter. Ja, äh, was ich letztens gelesen habe, was,
nur mal zu aktuellen Sachen, wo es auch richtig verschissen wird, was ich auch letztens gelesen
habe, wusstet ihr, dass es bei, ich will jetzt keinen Mist erzählen, irgendeinem Autohersteller,
ich bin mir jetzt nicht sicher welches, welches es ist, aber ist auch egal, die haben eine
extra Abteilung, wo sie sich überlegen, wie man die Sachen möglichst so formulieren kann
und so drehen kann, dass man, nicht Volkswagen, nein nie nicht, Volkswagen, das habe ich
auch gelesen, wie man die Sachen möglichst am besten so formuliert, so rechnet und so
dreht, dass man möglichst viele staatliche Corona-Hilfen abgreifen kann, also sprich,
die haben eine komplette Abteilung, die sich um nichts anderes kümmert, wie Corona-Hilfen
zu maximieren. So war das, glaube ich, ursprünglich mal gar nicht gedacht, aber da sieht man,
hey, scheiß drauf, wird gemacht, was geht. Mal ehrlich, ich würde es wahrscheinlich
an den ihrer Stelle genauso machen, aber das ist gar nicht so sehr das Problem, dass das
irgendeinen Hersteller ausnutzt, sondern dass das alles so geregelt ist, dass wenn du um
die Ecke guckst, demnächst jeder zweite Laden leer steht, aber wenn du ein riesen Autohersteller
bist, dann kriegst du Millionen. Also ich nehme es den Autoherstellern nicht wirklich
übel, dass sie das machen, das ist halt politisch verschissen geworden, dass das überhaupt
möglich ist. Ich meine, die nehmen ja noch nicht mal den kleinen Unternehmen, in dem
sind Geld weg, das Geld kommt ja bei den kleinen gar nicht an, die kriegen es ja gar nicht
gebacken, da mal was auszubezahlen. Es wurde ja kaum was ausbezahlt bisher. Nein, das ist
nicht, das ist kein Problem. Leute, das sehe ich komplett anders. Das ist nicht die Schuld
des, ähm, zumindest nicht die Hauptschuld des Autoanbieters, sondern das ist die Schuld
derjenigen, die die Regel gemacht haben. Und das sollte man mal viel öfters eigentlich
zum Thema machen, sich nicht irgendwie immer großartig darüber aufregen, was moralisch
verwerflich ist und sonstige Geschichten, sondern mal sehen, woher kommt es denn, ja,
woher kommt es denn auch, dass wir alle so ultra viele Steuern bezahlen und zumindest
für meinen Teil, ich kann ja nicht für alle sprechen, für meinen Teil, nicht unbedingt
so viel in die Bereiche kommt, die mir wichtig sind, ja. Hey, man, was überlege ich mir,
was ist mir wichtig? Mir ist wichtig, dass unser Gesundheitssystem gut funktioniert.
Mir ist wichtig, dass die Infrastruktur gut funktioniert, dass wir einen ordentlichen
öffentlichen Nahverkehr haben, dass wir ordentliche Straßen, Abwasser, sonst was haben,
dass Kinder Kindergartenplätze kriegen, dass es gute Ausbildung und Schulen gibt.
Könnte ich noch eine Weile weiter machen, ja. Da würde ich gerne meine Steuern sehen.
Dann würde ich wahrscheinlich auch gerne, Internetausbau, by the way, da würde ich
auch gerne Steuern bezahlen. Ich meine, ich bezahle viel Steuern, leider, es ist nicht
so, dass ich da scharf drauf bin, mache ich auch, ich habe kein Bock im Knast zu landen.
Aber wirklich freuen darüber tue ich mich nicht. Aber so ist es leider. So ist es leider.
Und da sollte man nicht so sehr darüber diskutieren, was da jetzt irgendwie moralisch
verwerflich ist oder was da, wie auch immer, man sollte eher darüber diskutieren, warum
sind die Regelungen eigentlich so scheiße, wie sie sind und wer hat die gemacht?
Natürlich ist die Lobby hart, klar, aber Lobby alleine sorgt nicht dafür, dass so was
so ist. Du brauchst immer noch Leute, die sich davon beschwätzen lassen und das am
Ende dann auch machen. Lobby allein, hey, ohne Scheiß, wenn ich Milliarden am Start
hätte, wenn ich Milliarden am Start hätte, dann würde ich auch neben jedem Typ, der
Einfluss hat, einen Sitzen hinsetzen, der den ganzen Tag was ins Ohr flüstert.
Natürlich ist das in gewisser Weise verwerflich, aber das eigentliche Problem ist gar nicht
mal so sehr, dass das ein Autohersteller das macht. Genauso wenig wie das ein Problem
ist, dass ein Autohersteller Vorstand irgendwie viel Geld bekommt oder so. Das Problem ist,
dass es dann auf offene Ohren trifft anscheinend, wenn man das lang genug macht. Das ist
eigentlich das Problem und ich finde persönlich, habe ich auch kein Problem damit, wenn, ich
finde es auch nicht unmoralisch, wenn ein Manager, Top Manager, Geschäftsführer, was
auch immer, einen Millionen Gehalt kriegt. Das finde ich nicht unmoralisch. Was ich problematisch
finde ist und wo man sich eigentlich mal Gedanken darüber machen muss, ist, den Typ hat jemand
eingestellt und die müsstest du eigentlich mal fragen. Guck mal, wenn einer zu euch sagt,
willst du 300 Euro mehr haben, dann sagt auch keiner nee. Oder umgedreht, ihr habt einen
Arbeitsvertrag abgeschlossen, in dem drinnen steht 2 Millionen und ihr kriegt nur eine,
dann sagt ihr auch nee, ich will aber zwei. Das eigentliche Problem ist, es hat die Typen
irgendjemand eingestellt, mit unter diesen Bedingungen und am Ende wollen sie das haben,
was im Vertrag steht. Das finde ich persönlich jetzt nicht irgendwie moralisch verwerflich.
Es gibt da schon noch ein paar Beispiele, die dann absichtlich sagen, sie verzichten
auf irgendwas, das macht natürlich auch ein bisschen gute Werbung für sie selbst, so
können sie sich als besonders gönnerhaft darstellen oder so. Aber das eigentliche Problem
ist, da muss man sich auflegen, irgendjemand hat den Typ eingestellt, für diese Kondition.
Die müsstest du eigentlich anschreisen, warum schließt ihr so einen beknackten Vertrag ab.
Das ist eine Sache, die ich mir allgemein ein bisschen mehr wünschen würde, ein bisschen
weniger Empörung über alles und jeden, sondern mal ein bisschen mehr. Leider ist das Wort
Querdenken mittlerweile negativ besetzt, aber deswegen sage ich mal, mal zumindest ein bisschen
versuchen, um die Ecke zu denken, wer hat denn eigentlich was von? Also sprich, warum
passieren Sachen so, wie sie passieren? Diagonal denken, ja? Warum gibt es Sachen?
Und wie gesagt, mit Top-Managern, die Millionen verdienen, ist es nicht so, dass der einfach
sich in den Vertrag schreiben kann, was er lustig ist, nein, den muss jemand eingestellt
haben zu den Konditionen. Natürlich hat er denen das Blaue vom Himmel runter versprochen
wahrscheinlich. Der war dann wahrscheinlich beim Vorstellungsgespräch, beim Vorstand
und hat gesagt, mit mir bekommen sie 30% Steigung im ersten Jahr, 40% Steigung, blablabla
und mit dem Bam, wir werden die besten, die geilsten. Natürlich hat er denen das Blaue
vom Himmel runter erzählt, aber die haben sich davon überzeugen lassen und haben gesagt,
okay, das ist der richtige Typ und dem geben wir jetzt 15 Millionen im Jahr. Hey, wenn
der einen Vertrag bekommt, wo 15 Millionen drin steht, dann sind die Typen Kacke, die
diesen Vertrag gemacht haben und sich beschwätzen haben lassen, nicht der Typ, der es am Ende
haben will. Sich gut zu verkaufen ist ja noch nicht strafbar. Übrigens, scheiße verkaufen
ist auch nicht strafbar. Ihr könnt heute auch Open-Source-Software nehmen und zum Download
anbieten hinter einer Paywall und jemand, der euch bezahlt dafür, ist halt dumm, aber
gegen Dummheit, das ist nicht verboten, ja. Die sind alle mal Peter Agile gewesen. Agile
heißt sie, habe ich mir sagen lassen. So, genug, genug drum rumgeladen, aber ich wollte
jetzt noch mal ganz kurz in den Chat gucken, da hat einer eben noch was Interessantes geschrieben
und dann fangen wir endlich mal an. Wir haben schon, wir haben schon fucking 21 Uhr gleich,
wir haben noch gar nichts gemacht. Dazu kommt übrigens auch, das muss ich noch ganz kurz
ergänzen sagen, dass diesen Job tatsächlich auch nicht viele Leute machen wollen und ich
glaube auch nicht viele Leute machen können. Also es ist nicht so easy, wie sich das manche
Leute vorstellen. Och, da werde ich halt mal nebenbei Top-Manager. Die stellen sich das
ein bisschen zu entspannt vor. By the way, ich finde die Idee gar nicht mal so schlecht,
weil man ein bisschen selbst, die Idee, das hatte ich lustigerweise, ich habe keine Ahnung,
ob es da irgendwie einen Namen für gibt, weil meistens haben sich sowas ja schon deutlich
schlauere Leute als ich überlegt. Die Idee hatte ich auch schon, ich habe keine Ahnung,
ob es wirklich funktioniert, aber ich hatte auch schon mal die Idee, wie wäre es denn
eigentlich, wenn man mit der Steuererklärung eine Gewichtung angeben könnte, wo man möchte,
dass sein Geld verteilt wird. Also sprich klar, man kann sich nicht komplett ausnehmen, aber
es wäre doch cool, wenn man eine Gewichtung angeben könnte, oder? Gut, wenn es dann halt
überhaupt nicht reicht, das muss man dynamisch handhaben, aber die Idee hatte ich auch schon.
Ich bin mir nicht sicher, ob das funktioniert, aber es wäre auf jeden Fall cool, wenn das
ging. Das hätte dann auch ein bisschen den Vorteil, dass man die unterschiedlichen Bereiche
halt attraktiv machen müsste, dass die Leute ihre Punkte drauf verteilen. Ja, das ist richtig,
das sehe ich auch so. Irgendwann habe ich noch etwas cooles gepostet, wo ich noch etwas
zu sagen wollte. Wir bezahlen ultra viel Steuern, mega viel Steuern. Das ist ja eigentlich
das, okay, wir machen heute zwar übelst viel Laberstimmung, das ist ja eigentlich eines
der größten Probleme, die wir haben, die irgendwie kaum jemand interessiert. Es leben so viele
Leute, die wirklich auf 40 Stunden die Woche arbeiten gehen, die jetzt vielleicht keinen
huge Job haben, wo sie 100.000 verdienen, aber die normale Jobs haben, also sagen wir
mal von Krankenpfleger bis Kassiererinnen oder Wurstverkäuferinnen oder sonst was,
also die einen ganz normalen Job haben. Die arbeiten 40 Stunden eventuell auch mehr und
haben am Ende Minus auf dem Konto im Monat. Das kann doch nicht sein. Es kann doch nicht
sein, dass einer wirklich 40 Stunden nennt man einen normalen Job macht und davon gibt
es leider viel zu viele und am Ende im Prinzip so gut wie nichts hat, um damit was zu machen
oder zumindest mal die theoretische Möglichkeit hat, so ein bisschen Vermögen aufzubauen.
Ich sehe das bei uns auf der Arbeit, es gibt total viele, auch welche in meinem Alter und
die vielleicht jetzt nicht die allerkleffersten Entscheidungen getroffen haben von wegen Haus
und Kinder und sowas, aber hey, das muss auch irgendjemand machen. Irgendjemand muss auch
Nachwuchs zeigen. Die haben am Ende des Monats plus minus Null und die schaffen 5 Tage und
teilweise Wochenende bis zum Umfallen. Also das finde ich auch nicht gut. Und dann fließen
die Dinger meiner Meinung nach auch in falsche oder zumindest teilweise in komplett falsche
Bereiche oder zumindest nicht in den Bereichen, wo ich mir das wünschen würde, wo mein Geld
verwendet wird. Und ja, wir bezahlen ultra viel Steuern und Strompreis, das ist auch nicht
wenig und ich verstehe nicht, warum das nicht mehr Leute realisieren, dass sie eigentlich
mehr haben sollten, also mehr unterm Strich haben sollten für ihre 40 Stunden die Woche
Arbeit. Ich habe nur 40 Stunden die Woche Arbeit, du kannst doch sonst nichts mehr großartig
machen. Du kannst ja nicht nebenbei nochmal eine Firma aufmachen oder sonst was. Bei manchen
ist es ja sogar so schlimm, die müssen dann abends noch irgendwo arbeiten gehen oder irgendwas
austragen oder sonst was. Also ich finde, wenn wirklich 40 Stunden die Woche Arbeit in
einem normalen, das ist ein großer Rahmen, normalen Job, der sollte auch wirklich genug
haben und sollte insofern auch genug haben, dass er sich was leisten kann von bzw. wenn
er was sparen will, was sparen will, dass er ein bisschen was aufbauen kann. Aber das
können viele Leute nicht und das suckt. Und dann werden immer irgendwelche Vergleiche
gezogen. So nach dem Motto, ja, uns geht es super gut und man muss sagen, ja, uns geht
es auch gut, wenn man, je nachdem welchen Maßstab man anlegt. Wenn man den Maßstab
anlegt, gut gehen bedeutet, darüber den Kopf zu haben und nicht verhungern zu müssen und
nicht an irgendwelchen Krankheiten abkratzen zu müssen. Okay, dann geht es uns gut. Also
die normalen Leute, ja. Dann geht es uns allen wunderbar. Also so wirklich absolut
krassen, essentiellen Sachen gibt es ja eigentlich nicht so viele Probleme. Aber wenn man das
mal sich anguckt, wir sind glaube ich die dritte, ich glaube wir sind die viertgrößte
Volkswirtschaft der Welt, so geldmäßig. Also ich weiß halt nicht, ob es der passende
Maßstab ist zu sagen, wir müssen nicht verhungern, uns geht es gut, wenn man Teil der viertgrößten
Volkswirtschaft ist. Ich meine, da müsste man ja schon ein bisschen, sagen wir mal,
etwas gehobenere Maßstäbe anlegen. Ich meine, viel mehr geht nicht Top 4, ne. Dementsprechend
sollten wir auch in vielen Bereichen eigentlich mindestens mal Top 5 sein. Was wir, by the
way, wir sind ja noch nicht mal, wir sind ja was Internetausbau geht. Top 5 ist ja noch
nett gesagt, also wir sind ja da Top 25, wenn überhaupt. Und wenn dann einer als Antwort
sagt, ja, aber es gibt doch welche, die noch schlechter sind. Natürlich gibt es immer
welche, die noch schlechter sind. Aber ich meine, das ist doch kein Wettbewerb, wer ist
noch schlechter? Das ist genauso, wenn sich die Leute immer drüber aufregen, so nach
dem Motto, oh, was weiß ich, die Linken haben was Böses gemacht, die Rechten haben was
Böses gemacht, ah, aber die anderen auch schon und jetzt die wieder. Das ist doch kein
Wettbewerb. Nur weil eine Seite kacke macht, heißt es nicht, die andere Seite hat jetzt
zweimal Kacke machen, Bonus frei. Also man kann doch Kacke nicht mit Kacke aufwiegen.
Wisst ihr wie ich meine, ich habe doch keinen Sinn. Ja, und deswegen sollten wir auch bei
solchen Themen wie Internetausbau, Infrastruktur und generell modernen Sachen eher sehen,
okay, warum sind wir eigentlich mit so viel Geld nicht Top 5? Und warum haben so viele
Leute eben keine Möglichkeit am Ende des Monats irgendwie was zu sparen, sich was zu
leisten, irgendwas aufzubauen? Was man ja eigentlich von dem Geld her haben müsste.
Deswegen verstehen jetzt da viel mehr Leute, die sagen, Alter, wie kann das sein, ich schaffe
mich hier 40 Stunden kaputt und habe am Ende nichts. Ex, Ex, Ex, Ex, Ex, Ex, Ex, Ex, Ex,
Pfiffmusik, ja. Ja. Deswegen, ich hab da meine Zweifel ob es uns wirklich so geht klar,
also es ist immer eine Maßstabsfrage, aber ich hab so meine Zweifel ob es wirklich den
Den Leuten angemessen gut geht im Durchschnitt sagen eher nicht
Ist ja ist ja auch so
Ich meine mehr steuern kann es ja aktuell kaum noch bezahlen es ist ja also es ist echt ist ja heftig was was da weggeht
Deswegen kann ich auch absolut nicht verstehen dass es tatsächlich leute gibt die die wirklich
betteln schon fast danach wir brauchen unbedingt mehr steuern für alles mögliche also wenn ihr mich fragt ich bezahle meiner meinung
meiner meinung schon genug
Du kannst nicht in rein den rein
prozentsatz nehmen und außerdem muss man sagen gerade in dänemark ich habe arbeitskollege der kommt aus dänemark gerade was
Das gesundheitssystem und soziale sachen angeht machen die mit dem geld aber auch was
Die machen mit dem geld auch was
Ich kann es auch nicht aus erster hand berichten weil ich noch nie in dänemark war
Aber du kannst nicht nach dem rein nach dem rein satz gehen und ja und selbst wann nur das ist auch wieder so nur weil andere
Noch mehr haben heißt es ja nicht dass es alles in ordnung ist ja du willst immer einen finden
Wo irgendetwas noch besser oder noch schlechter ist
Ach na
Das kann ich das verstehe ich nicht ich wie gesagt
Verstehe nicht dass es nicht mehr leuten gegen den strich geht
Dass sie 40 stunden arbeiten in der woche und kaum was übrig haben das verstehe ich nicht ich habe das problem glücklicherweise nicht
Ja ich habe ein haus geerbt
Ich habe mindestens zwei einnahmequellen ich verdiene auf der arbeit ganz gut ich verdiene mit dem rest ganz gut mich
Mich müsste eigentlich gar nicht jucken aber ich finde es trotzdem nicht nice
Vielleicht vielleicht gerade weil es weil es mich nicht juckt oder weil es mich nicht jucken muss
Dass ich mir das ein bisschen objektiver alles sehen kann kommt mir zumindest vor was ich
Ja easy money
Ja gut das ist ja auch richtig
Das ist ja auch richtig dass wir also es muss
Zumindest meiner ansicht nach
Infrastruktur mäßig muss
Internet nahverkehr
gesundheitsgeschichten es ist egal ob das unwirtschaftlich ist ein krankenhaus muss meiner meinung nach nicht wirtschaftlich sein
Ein krankenhaus muss in erster linie dafür da sein um die bevölkerung zu verhindern
und natürlich jetzt auch nicht unnötig das geld zum fenster rausschmeißt aber wenn ein krankenhaus plus minus null ist oder ein bisschen minus macht
finde ich persönlich jetzt kein problem
Aber du siehst ja jetzt schon dass den leuten komplettes personal wegrennt den kram will ja keiner mehr machen
Ich habe mich wieder ich frage mich wie das überhaupt funktionieren soll
Die krankenhaus muss in erster linie dafür da sein um die bevölkerung gut zu versorgen
Ich habe mich wieder ich frage mich wie das überhaupt funktionieren soll wenn ich schon mal irgendwann ins altersheim muss
Dann spricht da wahrscheinlich keiner mehr deutsch oder so
Das ist wahrscheinlich in amtssprache was haben wir denn auch wir werben glaube ich total viele leute aus polen an oder so zurzeit oder
tschechien oder so mein wegen die können das sicherlich auch die können das nicht schlechter oder so aber
Wir haben keinen mehr der das machen will
Ja wir sind wir sind wir sind gut da drin
Sachen irgendwo drauf zu projizieren ja
Also wir sind relativ gut da drin immer ein aus zu aus zu deuten der jetzt dran schuld ist
Das dumme da dran ist dass das selten dem der komplexität der situation gerecht wird
Aber simple sachen sind halt einfacher zu denken als komplizierte sachen deswegen macht ja jeder mal macht ja jeder mal dass man sich denkt
Die sind kacke der ist kacke dass es alles müll und daran liegt aber meistens ist es nicht so
Zumal die wahrheit falls sowas gibt wie die wahrheit oftmals eher in der mitte liegt als
Bei irgendwelchen extremen
Ja
Ich habe auch 37 halb gearbeitet wobei eigentlich um genau zu sein war es bei mir 37 37
45 oder so ganz schepp bezahl war das
30 37 45 oder so ganz schepp bezahl war das
Der stromstippe sind fortner drin sein das habe ich nicht gesehen
Die schweizer haben es gut weil die schweizer die verdienen ordentlich
Die haben viel höhere gehälter also am besten wäre eine schweiz aber in deutschland wohnen
Ja ich weiß ich kenne mich in der alten pflege nicht außer ich kann es mir vorstellen ich meine graben will ja
Keiner machen und es liegt nicht daran ist auch so eine diskussion die dann geführt wird nach dem motto das wäre irgendwie
moralisch verwehrpflicht dass keiner mehr im altenheim ist und so hey
Die leute und ich finde da trifft da trifft eigentlich die falschen die leute die so einen beruf ausüben bei uns das sind schon welche
Die beide augen zudrücken wenn es um ihr eigenes wohl geht oftmals
Und auch für unter scheißbedingungen zu wenig geld arbeiten und selbst die haben mittlerweile kein bock mehr drauf also darüber muss man sich eigentlich
Mal gedanken machen wie kriegt man es denn hin dass die leute nicht alle schreiend wegrennen wenn man zu ihnen sagt sie sollen
Alten pflege krankenpflege und vielleicht in kindergarten gehen
Aber das finde ich cool aber ich spiele halt kein fortnite aber wenn ich fortnite spiele würde ich würde ich mir tatsächlich den stonkstyp holen
Ja das stimmt deswegen sage ich ja am besten in schweiz geld bekommen in deutschland arbeiten
Ehh umgedreht in schweiz geld bekommen deutschland wohnen
Oder an der grenze oder so keine ahnung
Naja so vielleicht machen wir jetzt noch ein bisschen was würde ich sagen
Ja kann ich voll und ganz verstehen das bin da muss man sich entwundern dass das keiner machen will
Keine frage
So vielleicht vielleicht machen wir jetzt noch ein bisschen was
Es ist aktuell
Was ist schlimmer z++ oder steuern?
Oh das ist eine schwierige frage
Naja z++ weil
Ich mein
Es gibt einfach nichts was schlimmer ist als z++
Steuern passiert wenigstens zum teil noch ein bisschen was mit was ich was mir auch was bringt ja
Das ist übrigens das ist übrigens ein super ein super thema da muss ich da muss ich jetzt was muss ich jetzt was zu sagen
Das ist ein super beispiel mit preise
Wo versucht wird mit bullshit von der von der eigentlichen realität abzulenken und zwar
Ihr habt doch alle die diskussion mitbekommen mit preis bremse und generell dass in deutschland frankfurt. Es ist ja auch so dass einfach
Der scheiss zu viel kostet gibt es ja in vielen städten diskussion drüber und
Da wurde dann ernsthaft die diskussion losgetreten wie
Die diskussion losgetreten wie unmoralisch die vermieter sind so viel geld für ihre wohnung zu verlangen
Und da muss ich halt erst mal ganz klar sagen
Das ist nicht unmoralisch
Als vermieter für sein eigentum das zu verlangen was man verlangen will
Du bist vollkommen frei was deine es solltest du zumindest sein was deine was deine vertragsgestaltung angeht
Das ist das ist nicht das unmoralisch und das ist nicht das problem an der ganzen sache
Das problem ist und das ist das womit solchen diskussionen davon abgelenkt werden soll das problem ist dass man das fragt mich nicht die letzten zehn jahre
absolut verschissen hat auszubauen
Mit halbwegs bezahlbaren wohnungen ja in frankfurt wird jetzt beispielsweise komplett neuer stadtteilen gebaut so muss es machen
Hey, wie viel dann man sich am ende leisten kann sei mal dahingestellt aber
Natürlich kannst du es zehn jahre zehn plus jahre
Verscheißen und dann mit solchen diskussionen von der eigentlich von deinem eigentlichen versagen ablenken und das ist was
Was ich finde passiert total oft es wird scheiße gebaut über jahre wenn ich jahrzehnte
Und dann damit die leute nicht auf die idee kommen wir haben es ja verschissen die letzten zehn jahre werden solche komischen
solche komischen ablenkungs manöver gestartet wie die diskussion
Vermieter ihr seid aber böse und unmoralisch dass ihr vor euer eigentum das verlangt was ihr wollt
Das problem ist dass nicht ausgebaut wurde
Das ist das ist so dumm und die leute die leute fallen auch voll drauf rein
Die leute fallen auch voll drauf rein
Und sind dann wieder wahnsinnig empört und wird eine riesen diskussion losgetreten
Wie schlimm das mit vermietern ist und alles säcke und da kommen die ersten leute wieder mit ihren stories. Oh ja
Mein vermieter ist auch ein arsch da kommt der erste ja ich hatte einen ausländischen nachname ich kriege auch keine wunde hauen sie alle ihre stories raus
Und das lenkt vom eigentlichen problem ab dass der kram nicht ausgebaut wurde
Das liegt nicht an den vermietern die haben die haben es politisch verschissen
Und das wird halt versucht mit solchen ablenkungs manövern zu verschleiern
Das sagt halt dass die leute auch so alles dann immer drauf springen
Und sich aufregen müssen anstatt man sich einfach ein bisschen gedanken zu machen ey wer hat denn da jetzt was von wenn man sich
Da drüber aufregt ja die jenige die es eigentlich verkackt haben und keiner an sie denkt dass sie es verkackt haben
Ja übrigens gibt es gibt auch noch eine sache um jetzt mal vielleicht ein bisschen zu etwas lustigeren themen zu kommen
Weiß dass ich heute eigentlich programmieren wollte vielleicht auch gleich noch was oder vielleicht guckt man noch das semper video
Aber auch eine sache die ich nicht verstehe ist
Ne muss ja nicht sein aber das ist nicht das problem von den vermietern
Die den vermietern gehört das ich finde es auch nicht ich finde es auch nicht sinnvoll
Dass es so wenig gibt und dass man das deswegen so viel dafür verlangen kann
Aber du kannst es ja den vermieter kann sie nicht den vermietern den vorwurf machen dass sie das dass sie das machen
Die stelle ist ja auch nicht so sinnvoll
Die stadt muss letztendlich dafür sorgen dass es genug bezahlbare wohnungen gibt und genug ausgebaut wenn man das die letzten zehn jahre lang nicht macht
Und lieber neue neue neue etagen auf etage baut oder sowas in der richtung kein wunder dass das so teuer ist
Das
Wird mich mich würde tatsächlich ich kann dazu zu wenig sagen aber mich würde tatsächlich
In ein paar jahren meine analyse ähm interessieren ein paar stonks crafts was nach der mietpreisbremse passiert ist mit den mit den
Preisen
Das ist es ganz klar das ist es ganz klar das ist es ganz klar das ist es ganz klar das ist es ganz klar das ist es ganz klar das ist es ganz klar
Done
Das ist das gleiche wie wenn die bahnen
Wie sieht es denn aus, wir enteignen einfach ein paar Leute, da kommen wir vielleicht irgendwann auch noch hin, aber das kann es natürlich auch nicht sein.
Ich sehe das übrigens mit Krankenhäusern ähnlich, ich bin der Meinung Krankenhäuser
Krankenhäuser sind nicht dafür gedacht Gewinn zu machen, Krankenhäuser sollen die Leute versorgen
Und wenn die plus minus null sind ist okay, wenn die ein bisschen drauflegen ist auch durchaus okay, dafür würde ich dann auch gerne Steuern bezahlen
Wenn ich wüsste, dass die Leute nicht mehr, ich will nicht sagen wie scheiße behandelt werden, das klingt jetzt zu übertrieben, aber
nicht mehr wie rein wie
Topf aus Geld quasi behandelt werden, wenn du zum Arzt gehst, so nach dem Motto oder war schon da diesen Monat, da kriege ich jetzt
jetzt keine 8,50 Euro mehr, deswegen verlegen wir den anders oder war zum dritten Mal da, da kriegen wir jetzt gar nichts für
Wir können ihm das Knie operieren, das bringt
10.000 Euro, wenn wir gucken, dass er was er wirklich hat, dann bringt das viel weniger, das finde ich kacke
Ja, die sollen gucken, dass den Leuten gut geht und das machen und für sie da sind, wobei ich mir sicher bin, das wollen viele Ärzte auch
aber die Umstände
erlauben es viel nicht
So und jetzt mal jetzt mal eine lustigere Sache, wo ich mich auch frage
warum das, warum das so ist, wie es ist
Kennt ihr die Schlangen vor Postfilialen oder vor DHL-Lehnen aktuell?
Habt ihr das vielleicht auch schon mal in letzter Zeit gesehen?
Also ihr geht an der Post vorbei, ihr geht an DHL-Lehnen vorbei, das ist eine riesen Schlange vor DHL-Lehnen und Postlehnen
Leute mit Pakete, Leute, die irgendwas abholen wollen, ich meine mir ist klar, warum die Schlange da ist, weil sie nicht mehr alle rein dürfen, ist schon logisch
Aber bei uns ist beispielsweise nicht weit weg, ist eine Post
Schlange, Schlange, wirklich bis zum Parkplatz Schlange
Was ich mich frage ist
Warum machen das die Leute?
Ich meine, ich meine nicht Corona
Ich meine, ich meine nicht, mir ist klar, dass die Leute abstandhalten wegen Corona, aber ich meine
Aber warum machen die Leute das überhaupt?
Das verstehe ich nicht, es gibt doch zig Alternativen
Packstation zum Beispiel, du kannst anrufen zum Abholen, du kannst einem DHL-Fahrer mitgeben, du kannst Hermes oder
DPD oder was auch immer benutzen, du kannst was kleines in eine Waren-Sendung machen und selbst ausdrucken, das Etikett oder oder per Handydings-App
Zahl drauf schreiben, es gibt
50 Möglichkeiten was zu verschicken und zu bekommen
Ohne dass man bei DHL-Schlange stehen muss, aber warum sind die Leute nicht dazu in der Lage das zu machen?
Weil ich habe hier eine Vermutung, woran das liegt, ich glaube die Leute sind eigentlich noch
In Wirklichkeit gehirnmäßig viel mehr Boomer als richtig krasse Boomer
Also ihr wisst, ich bin auch 36, ich bin auch schon hier, alles 30 plus ist Boomer mittlerweile
Und ich glaube die sind im Kopf eigentlich nicht in der Lage mit aktueller Infrastruktur umzugehen
Weil mal ehrlich gesagt, es ist es ist eigentlich total einfach, ja du machst dein Handy auf oder setzt daheim ein Rechner
Und guckst einfach mal eine halbe Stunde, okay was sind aktuell in Corona-Zeiten die beste Möglichkeit
Pakete zu verschicken und zu empfangen und da willst du relativ schnell drauf kommen, dass es überhaupt nicht
notwendig ist sich von einem DHL-Store zu stellen
Aber die Leute sind dazu irgendwie in der Lage, das verstehe ich nicht, das sind so Dinge die gehen mir einfach in den Kopf rein
Das kann man
Stripes, das kann man, ich habe damals angerufen bei DHL und habe gesagt, weil ich habe mich, das ist auch so ein Ding, ich habe mich übelst mal gestritten
Ich habe mir gesagt, ich habe mich gestritten, aber ich habe mir gesagt, ich habe mich gestritten, ich habe mich gestritten
Bei DHL und habe gesagt, weil ich habe mich, das ist auch so ein Ding, ich habe mich übelst mal gestritten mit den Leuten bei der DHL-Filiale
Bei mir und ich habe danach bei DHL bei der Hotline angerufen, habe gesagt, sie sollen nie wieder, wenn ich nicht da bin
Die Sache an diese Filiale zustellen, sie sollen es entweder eins weiter abgeben
bei mir über den Zaun schmeißen
Nachbar geben, am nächsten Tag noch mal kommen oder zurückschicken
Ich werde nie wieder im Leben in dieses Filiale gehen und etwas abholen und
Ehrlich gesagt, bis jetzt hat es auch fast immer, bis auf wenige Ausnahmen, fast immer funktioniert
Aber nee, ernsthaft, also die Filiale ist wirklich mega beschissen, übrigens auch die Filiale wo total viele Leute davor stehen
Nee, aber ich, da gehe ich auch nicht mehr hin
Ich war, ich bin da mal hingegangen
Und ich, ich, ich weiß gar nicht, was ich verschicken wollte, ich wollte irgendwas verschicken
Irgendetwas, wo man ein extra Päckchen gebraucht hat für
Und da habe ich der, da habe ich der, der Frau da erklärt, was ich verschicken will
Und da habe die gefragt, was ich denn brauche
Ja, habe ich mir gedacht, hey, scheiß drauf, fragst du mal die Profis, ja, ich habe auch im Internet gucken können, alles selbst machen
Weiß ich nicht, da meint die hier, wir haben hier so ein Pack, so ein Paket-Set
Und das wäre genau das Richtige für
Und da habe ich das Paket-Set gekauft
Und einen Tag später habe ich das eingepackt
Mit dem Paket-Set, was die mir verkauft hat
Und da bin ich, bin ich, bin ich zu der gleichen Tussi hin
Und habe ihr das geben wollen, da meint sie, das Paket ist zu groß
Hab ich gesagt, ich war gestern da
Und habe sie gefragt
Das war doch die gleiche
Was ich nehmen soll, ich habe gesagt, dieses Paket-Set
Und dann hat sie ernsthaft behauptet, ich will das machen
Und dann hat sie ernsthaft behauptet, das stimmt nicht
So hätte sie mir das nicht gesagt
Muss ich auch sagen
Warum sollte ich denn sonst das Paket
Kauft, dieses Paket-Set kaufen, wenn es dafür nicht da ist
Das witzige war, meine Mutter war damals sogar noch mit dabei
Und
Dann hat die sich sogar an die gewandelt
Und hat gesagt, fragen sie doch mal ihre Mutter, die war doch dabei
Alter, ich meine, ich bin 36
Will ich mich, will ich mich verarschen
Da wollte sie sich, da wollte sie sich übelst rausreden
Und
Tja, da war ich halt echt stinkig
Danach habe ich gleich mal DHL angerufen
Hab gesagt, nee, ich werde nie wieder
In diese Filiale, kein Fuß in diese Filiale setzen
Hätte die nicht so dämlich reagiert
Hätte die vielleicht sogar gesagt, wie es
Wirklich ist, sie hat sich vertan
Da habe ich kein Problem mit
Wenn einer zugibt
Genau, fragen sie ihren Erziehungsberechtigten
Mit 36
Wenn einer zugibt, dass er sich vertan hat
Da bin ich der Letzte, der irgendwie sagt
Du Sack
Oder in dem Fall
Sackinnen wäre dann das richtige
Du Sack
Hier, fick dich, würde ich nicht machen, hätte ich gesagt
Okay, dann gucken wir das, was sie irgendwie umpacken
Aber, dass sie
So richtig beschissen reagiert hat
Dann gehe ich nie wieder rein
Vielleicht siehst du viel zu jung aus
Weiß nicht
Glaube ich nicht
Naja
Hätte man aufnehmen müssen
Ich soll einfach keinen Scheiß erzählen
Das ist ja kein Verhör
Oder so bei der Post
Genau
Paketstation ist auch so ein Ding
Also es gibt wirklich
Hat der noch der OnlyFans
Wo komme ich jetzt hier raus
Okay, das ist eine coole
Das ist eine coole, das ist eine coole April
Jebaited Idee
Aber wenn der
Macht damit sogar noch ordentlich Kohle
Das gibt irgendwelche Verrückten, die das tatsächlich kaufen
Einfach nur aus Just For Fun
Vielleicht, ja ich glaube nicht, dass ich
Zu Zoomer mäßig aussehe
Okay Leute, wir haben nicht mehr
Allzu viel Zeit, ich würde sagen wir machen das
Wir machen das
Okay Leute
Okay Leute, was haltet ihr davon
Was haltet ihr davon, ich habe eine Frage
Wollen wir noch versuchen mal
Eine halbe Stunde Proggers zu machen
Und dann gucken wir das Semper Video zu
Telekom und Filternet
Und dann gehe ich pennen
Speedrun
Also ich wollte euch ja eigentlich noch erklären
Was wir machen
Ich wollte euch ja eigentlich noch erklären was wir machen
Also für alle die das letzte Mal nicht dabei gewesen sind
Wir haben hier so ein paar Sensoren
Und zwar Miflora Sensoren
Das sind eigentlich Sensoren
Die sind dafür gedacht, dass man die in Blumentöpfe stopft
Maurice Feierdach, doch
Die stopft man in Blumentöpfe
Und die reporten dir dann
Bodenfeuchtigkeit, also wie feucht
Die Erde ist, wie viel Dünger
Und Mineralien da drin sind, wie die Temperatur ist
Und wie der Lichteinfall ist
Also das ist eigentlich
Eine coole Idee
Aber
Geht es immer noch um das Grab
Nein geht es nicht mehr
Aber ich habe mir überlegt
Wisst ihr wofür die Sachen, also die im letzten Stream dabei sind
Die wissen es, wofür diese Sache eigentlich noch
Viel besser ist
Als
Pflanzen zu überwachen
Als Kühlschrank Monitor
Weil Temperatur und Licht
Ist der optimale Sensor
Für den Kühlschrank
Licht, ob die Tür noch offen ist, zumindest
Soweit das Licht an ist
Und Temperatur, ob mit dem Kühlschrank
Was nicht stimmt, dass Strom weg ist
In die Pumpe irgendwie kaputt, was auch immer
Also das ist eine optimale Überwachung
Das mit dem Kühlschrank alles in Ordnung ist
Und das gute ist, das Ding ist wireless
Das geht per Low-Energy-Bluetooth
Und
Überträgt aus dem Kühlschrank auch noch Sachen
Also sprich eigentlich
Massive Big Brain das Ding
Und ich habe
Das auch letzten Stream in Kühlschrank gelegt
Wir haben was programmiert, um das auszulesen
Und das funktioniert prinzipiell auch
Und genau
Das haben wir gemacht
So
Das Problem ist jetzt nur, ich zeige euch das mal
Was das eigentlich Problem ist
Ich kompiliere das mal und zeige euch das Problem
Also ich kann auf dem
Achso, übrigens worauf wir das laufen lassen
Ist so ein Ding, so ein kleiner ESP32
Controller
Und ihr seht schon
Ich habe ungefähr 2 MB
Speicherplatz
1,9 MB, sagen wir mal
Speicherplatz auf dem Controller
Und ich habe jetzt schon
1,2 MB
Belegt und ihr seht, ich mache nichts
Ich mache einen Bluetooth-Scan
Und schreibe ein paar Werte
Raus
Kannst du nicht
Einen ESP32-866
mit Temp- und Photosensor nehmen
Rein für die Sensoren könnte ich das machen
Das Problem ist, dass
Die Dinger zu viel Strom verbrauchen
Und WLAN mag es auch nicht so gerne
Aus dem Kühlschrank und generell aus
Metall
Metallkäfigen zu senden
Aber das hauptsächliche Problem
Am ESP2866 dürfte die
Batterielaufzeit sein
Und selbst mit Deep Sleep verbrauchen die zu viele
Verbrauchen die zu viel
Es gibt Lösungen mit einer Uhr
Die das Ding regelmäßig aufwecken
Und sonst wie, gibt es
Aber die sind auch noch eine ganze Ecke teurer
Als so einen Sensor
BLE ist auch 2,4 GHz
Da hast du recht
Tja
Dann ist das nicht das Problem
Dann ist das egal
Nein, nein, hat es nicht
Hat es nicht
Der ESP2866 hat eventuell
Rein der
Der Chip
Hat vielleicht
4 µA oder so
Aber die Boards drum herum
Die haben noch zig Sachen an
Sei es irgendwelche Spannungswandler, die permanent aktiv sind
Oder aber auch
Memory, was du aktiv lassen musst
Das nach dem Deep Sleep noch da ist
Kommst du im Leben nicht auf
4 µA
Das geringste
Also das kleinste was ich habe ist ein ESP32
Das kenne ich
Aber das du kommst nicht
Du kommst nicht auf 4 µA
Realistisch betrachtet
Das einzige was du machen kannst ist mit einer Uhr
Die das Ding regelmäßig aufweckt und alles abschaltet
Und einen D1 Mini kriegst du
Kriegst du auch nur so gering
Wenn du selbst dran rumlötest und sowas
Wir können uns den Artikel malen gucken
Ähm
Ja
Ey komm mal hier sind wir halt schon bei 20 µA
Das ist schon mal eine ganze Ecke mehr
Als 4 µA
Die jemand im Chat geschrieben hat
Meinen wir 0,4 µA
Sind nicht
Sind nicht irgendwie 4 µA
Oder so
Aber das sind 400 µA
So
Ähm
Ja und du musst selbst
Daran rumlöten
Das ist keine gute Lösung
Also das geringste
Das wirklich geringste
Was ich bisher gemessen habe
Ist ein
Ist so eine
Und das Board ist explizit
Auf Deep Sleep ausgelegt also sprich
Ähm
Der schaltet jeglichen Spannungswandler ab
Und hat direkt einen Eingang für eine Batterie
Was übrigens der D1 Mini auch nicht hat
Was aber auch nicht wirklich notwendig ist
Das ist somit das beste Produkt
Was ich bisher gefunden habe
Für wirklich Deep Sleep und Power Sparen
Unter sagen wir mal sogar
Unter 10 µA
Deep Sleep und alle ESP32
Features das ist nice
Aber nichtsdestotrotz finde ich den Bluetooth Sensor
Wenn man den eh schon hat
Und von den Features her im Prinzip
Besser
Der ist halbwegs wasserdicht
Ich weiß das da aus dem Kühlschrank rauskommt
Da die passenden Sensoren
Tja
Die kleinen ESP
Sind da nicht der richtige Maßstab
Für in dem Video, weil
Die sitzen ja eigentlich auf keinem Board
Was sonst noch irgendwas hat
Wie gesagt ich kenne das
Auch schon beschäftigt und
10 µA
Ist schon verdammt wenig
Für einen Stock
ESP266 Board
Und in der Regel
Mit den meisten Boards auch nur möglich
Wenn man dran rumlötet
Und äh
Noch andere zig Verrenkungen macht
Dann ist es tatsächlich besser
Man kauft sich so einen hier, der explizit dafür gedacht ist
Der auch nicht so viel mehr kostet
Das hat auch Probleme nicht
Genau
Da brauchst du auch einen passenden Akku dazu
Also
Diese Bluetooth Sensoren
Haben da eindeutig so
Die Edge wie man so schön sagt
Zumal das Gute ist
Ich hab davon auch noch ein paar
Ja das kommt drauf an
Das ist das nächste Problem
Das kommt drauf an
Die meisten dürften das verkraften
Aber im Zweifelsfall
Brauchst du dann auch irgendeine Spannungswandler davor
Oder du brauchst
Wo wir da binden Board, was einen expliziten Eingang
Für Batterien hat
Die gehen dann auch bis 4,2 Volt
Ich glaube sogar toleranzmäßig bis 4,8
Die Batterie Eingänge
Also was auch wieder dafür spricht
Nicht irgendwie einen Board
Was nicht dafür gedacht ist umzulöten
In der Hoffnung ist Deep Sleep
Doch irgendwie gut
Sondern wenn schon, wenn man sowas machen will
Ein Projekt dann sich einen Board zu kaufen
Was explizit für Deep Sleep Sachen gedacht ist
So
Genau
So und wie gesagt
Das probieren wir
Um jetzt nochmal
Was zu diesem Sensor zu sagen
Ich hab mir davon irgendwie mal einen 10er Pack bestellt
Und davor hatte ich schon mal einen 5er Pack bestellt
Und ich hab die für unter 10 Dollar das Stück gekriegt
Die waren mal ultra billig im Angebot
Sonst hätte ich die auch nicht bestellt
Und ich hab davon auch genug
Das heißt für mich ist optimal diesen Sensor zu verwenden
So und das Problem was ich hab ist
Was sonst
Leute, Leute
Eine Sache wisst ihr ja mittlerweile schon
Die länger dabei ist. Ich bestell nie einzelne Sachen
Ich bestell entweder
Mindestens einen 3er Pack, wenn ich noch nicht weiß
Ob das was taugt und ob ich das wirklich verwenden will
Besser gleich 5er, 10er Pack
Manchmal übertreib ich es
Auch ein bisschen. Ich hab mir einen 100er Pack
USB Kabel bestellt
Das war vielleicht, ich muss jetzt zugeben
Auch wenn ich es ungern zugebe
Das war vielleicht ein bisschen viel
Oder war es so ein 50er Pack USB Kabel
Chat 100er Pack oder 50er Pack
Ich weiß es gar nicht, ich hab es euch aber erzählt
Nur 50er Pack
Ich weiß es, ich hab es aber
Moment, ich hab es in einem Video gezeigt
Ich hab es in einem Video gezeigt
Moment
Hallo Jungs
Moment, Moment, Moment
Hier, hier
Guck mal mal, welche
Äh, sage ich bestimmt im Video auch
Wenn nicht mein Name drauf steht
Fuck, da steht überall mein Name drauf
Gut, dann zeige ich es euch so
50, ok
Nur 50, nur 50 USB Kabel
Ich hab mir 50
50 USB Kabel gekauft
50 USB Kabel
Und ich gebe zu, das war vielleicht
ein bisschen viel
Aber das geile an den USB Kabel ist
Also die USB Kabel sind wirklich
Poggers
Die haben
Guckt mal
Ein
Die haben einen Mikro USB
und einen USB C in einem
Ich glaube
ein bisschen länger als einen Meter sind die Dinger
Die Chinesen nehmen es nicht so genau
mit den Maßen
Christian Stripes
Besser haben als brauchen
Ja
Das ist ja fast wie bei
Wie heißen sie? Bauforum 24
News
Die haben so ein T-Shirt mit dem
Spruch drauf
So als Werkzeugfan gucke ich
da manchmal
Mit Adapter ist
sehr praktisch
Exzellent
Und mein Controller
Also der da
Der hat bloß 4 MB Flash
Und 4 MB Flash
Setzen sich folgendermaßen zusammen bei mir aktuell
1,9 MB
Für Firmware 1
Für Firmware 2
Ein bisschen Zusatzkram noch
Für Files und ein bisschen Zusatzkram für
2% Storage wenn man sowas speichern muss
Unabhängig von der Firmware
Warum 2x Firmware? Na klar
Dass ich Updates machen kann über WLAN
Falls man
So und das dumme ist
Ihr sehts
Wenn ich diese Bluetooth Library verwende
sind 60% Flash
Speicher schon voll und ich habe es vorhin
ausprobiert
Wenn ich noch WIFI anmache
Ich brauche ja
WLAN
Das machen wir jetzt mal testweise
Ich mache mal so eine Fake WLAN Verbindung
Dann werdet ihr sehen
Dass die Geschichte sogar
Jetzt schon
Postchamp
Jetzt sogar schon 84%
So
Und wenn ich da noch ein paar Helper Libraries
drauf mache und einen Web Server
Für OTA Update
Dann ist schlicht und ergreifend
Nicht genug Platz
Im Flash
Für meine Firmware und ihr sehts ich mache nichts
Das ist alles was ich im aktuellen
Sketch mache
Das ist das Problem mit der mitgelieferten
Firmware mit der mitgelieferten Bluetooth
Den Serial beginn runtersetzen
Dann ist die Nummer ja kleiner
What
She baited
Weil es ergibt keinen Sinn
Ja gut die No
Da ist die Nummer nicht
Ich darf mich nicht so sehr durch Chat
Dinger verwirren lassen
Aber es gibt jetzt
Mehrere Möglichkeiten was man machen kann
Man kann ein paar Compilerflex setzen
Aber das ist schon auf Größe optimiert
Was man machen kann ist
Man könnte zum Beispiel
So wie der Chat das gerade sagt
Man könnte selbst
Eine WLAN Implementierung schreiben
Die kleiner ist
Ja das könnte man machen
Debugging off brauche ich nicht
Also gibt es nicht viel was ich ausschalten kann
Bringt auch nicht viel
Ein bisschen was aber nur ein paar Kilobyte nicht viel
Was man machen kann ist
Ich habe jetzt nämlich im Vorfeld schon angeguckt
Man macht genau das was der Chat vorschlägt
Nur
Dass man es nicht selber programmiert
Sondern auf GitHub ein Projekt nimmt
Die das machen für einen
Es gibt nämlich auch eine
WLAN Implementierung
Die das machen für einen
Es gibt nämlich anstatt dieser
Bluetooth Library gibt es eine
Viel bessere
Wie sagt man so schön
Low Profile
Bluetooth
Library die das macht
Unter der Haube benutzen sie das gleiche
Die ESP32
Low Level Bluetooth Library
Aber der Rapper ist nicht so groß
Das heißt
Das da brauchen wir
Nimble
Das ist quasi ein
Bluetooth Slow Energy
Baum Sloterdown
Muss der Darkreader
Gerade meine
Meine GitHub Credentials
Rüber schicken
Von Shithub
Der Darkreader ist es ernsthaft
Ist es ernsthaft der Darkreader
Das glaube ich nicht
Off
Der Darkreader
Leute
Der Darkreader gebadet
Jetzt gehts okay was auch immer
Ich glaube ich starte meinen Firefox neu
Haben die den Darkreader
An die Chinesen verkauft
Ist der Darkreader
An Chinesen verkauft und
Ist nicht mal der Darkreader
Darkreader GitHub
An die Chinesen
Hat er von Amazon verkauft
Slow Rendering Times
Okay anscheinend noch nicht verkauft an die Chinesen
Nicht verkauft an die Chinesen
Einfach einen Bug wie es aussieht
Bestimmt
Nice der erste April Joke
Erstmal fürs Deinstallieren des Addons sorgen
So genau
Diese Library verwenden wir jetzt
Und die ist angeblich
Viel Low Leveliger Profiliger
Nein
Ich hab noch kein Edgard installiert
Deswegen probieren wir das mal schnell aus
Das können wir noch machen bis wir später aufmüssen
Lip
Zack install
Da ist es
Und zwar Library installieren
In den Coolchamp
So und angeblich ist sie sogar
Rückwärtskompatibel
Ich muss jetzt nur noch das einbinden
Es sollte 1 zu 1 Rückwärtskompatibel sein
Funktioniert
Ist es aber nicht ich seh schon
Das wär jetzt auch zu einfach gewesen
Wenn es einfach funktioniert
Aber es ist erstaunlich viel intakt geblieben muss ich sagen
Es ist erstaunlich viel intakt geblieben
Ach guck mal das sind Aliasse
Die alten haben sie Alias auf das neue
Ok
Ok da müssen wir das mal schnell fixen
Also habt ihr euch gemerkt wie groß die
Firmware ist
Wir sind jetzt bei 84,8%
Mal gucken wie das jetzt mit der neuen
Bluetooth Firmware ist
Also was ich da noch unterbringen muss
Also WLAN
Hab ich ja schon
Web Server für OTA
Ein MQTT Client
Und ein bisschen MQTT
Staff für Sensoren
Und das Ding
Ist einfach voll
Das passt da nicht drauf
Auf den Flash normal
So also wie kriegen wir das jetzt gefixt
As Service Data
Have Service Data
Können wir so lassen
Get
Get Native und dann wie gehts weiter
Moment das hier oben stimmt doch schon nicht
Moment
Schauen wir mal Examples
Warum lässt du eigentlich den Web Server direkt auf dem Controller laufen
Weil ich über den Web Server Firmware Updates machen kann
Und das ist praktischer wenn es direkt auf dem Controller läuft
Ich mein ja
Du könntest den Web Server theoretisch
Auf Raspberry Pi oder woanders laufen lassen
Und so ein
Minimal Kommunikation machen
Mit deinem Controller
Und dann die Firmware da hochschieben
Das wird auch funktionieren
Aber ich mag Sachen
Ich mag Sachen die so
Self Contains sind irgendwie
So alles auf einem
Das einfach
Für sich genommen funktioniert
So
Schauen wir mal Scanner
Mal das Example angucken
What
Das ist Byte Reihenfolge umdrehen
Oder was
Okay also ich mach das hier übrigens verkehrt
Ich brauche hier
Ne
Ach guck mal das ist jetzt ein Pointer
Vorher war das
Vorher war das ein
Direkte
Tja was war es denn überhaupt
Ich hab keine Ahnung wie wir sind
Normalerweise hast du ein Value oder eine Reference
Aber ich hab keine Ahnung was das in C++
Alles ist
So das heißt wir müssen das jetzt auch zu einem Pointer machen
Das hier auch zu einem Pointer
Und das hier
Passt das jetzt
U16
Ich hoffe mal dass das jetzt alles in Ordnung ist
U16 jawoll
Gibt es da noch mehr
Ah Value alles klar
UID bla bla das können wir alles gleich lassen
Get Service Data
Ah
Ich glaube das sollte funktionieren
Mal gucken wie groß das jetzt ist
Merkt euch 84,8
hatten wir vorher
Und jetzt ist das ganze
Nur noch
Postchamp
Bäm
40 Leute
Da krieg ich jetzt auch noch was drauf!
Ja.
So, wir müssen jetzt nochmal kurz überprüfen, ob der Kram auch funktioniert.
Ich schließ mal kurz den Controller an.
Nicht, dass es jetzt irgendwie kaputt ist oder so.
Hallo?
Alter, USB ist immer falsch rum.
Immer falsch rum.
Hä?
Ist das dumm?
Ach, ich hab das falsche USB-Kabel, null.
Kein Wunder.
Mini-USB und Mikro-USB funktioniert nicht so gut, würde ich sagen.
So.
Upload.
So, und jetzt müssen wir noch rauskriegen, wie der Batteriestand ist, aber ich fürchte,
das kriegen wir heute noch mal hin.
So, wo hab ich denn hier den Sensor?
Sensor-Man.
Wo ist er?
Wo ist der Sensorik-Man?
Da.
Auf, sende mal was.
Sende mal was.
Ich muss gucken, ob es noch funktioniert.
Was passiert?
Beginn 9007, sind das drei?
Ne, das stimmt nicht.
Das stimmt nicht.
Weil, dass unter der Haube der gleiche Datentyp ist.
Okay, scheint nicht zu funktionieren, oder?
Oder funktioniert's?
Also, er macht, er macht glaub ich nix.
Okay, kommentieren wir, kommentieren wir den Kram einfach noch mal ein.
Kommentieren wir den Kram einfach noch mal ein und gucken, ob das, ob das prinzipiell
was macht.
Echt?
Wundert mich jetzt.
So, aber wir haben ja jetzt hier nix geändert, das müsste eigentlich so weiter funktionieren.
Auf, upload, let's go.
Kann es sein, dass unser Serial abgeschissen ist?
Weil's Uploaden auch nicht geht?
Ich glaub, unser Serial ist abgeschissen, wir hätten, wir hätten eigentlich schon was
gesehen, aber aus irgendwelchen Gründen ist die, hallo?
What the f...
What?
Alter, übelst kaputt gerade.
Okay, weißt du was, lull.
Wir rebooten einfach.
Es ist zwar, es ist zwar Windows-Taktik, aber Windows-Taktik funktioniert manchmal unter
Linux auch.
Vielleicht hat er Probleme gehabt mit Standby, ich mache die, ich mache die VM immer auf
pausiert, anstatt neu zu starten, wobei, nee, ich hab heute neu gestartet, ach, dann weiß
ich auch nicht.
So, und wenn das geht, gucken wir noch das Semper-Video, bevor ich pennen gehe.
Puma müde, Puma schlafen, wisst ihr ja.
So, hat er jetzt, ah, guck mal, da ist es.
Da ist es, Leute.
Es funktioniert, und das Ganze mit viel weniger Speicherplatz.
Also, Wi-Fi-Beginner habe ich zum Glück wieder rausgemacht, ja.
Be root, sondern reboot, ja, ist so.
Guck mal, 25,4 ist es hier, das kann tatsächlich sein, meine Heizung steht auf 24, ich habe
die Tür zu, zwei Monitore, zwei Rechner an, hier ist es ordentlich warm drin, ja.
Okay, das passt, also wir haben 92 Lux, Luft, nicht Luft, was laber ich denn, Licht, Einstrahlung,
und 25,4 Grad, okay, passt, nice, aber ihr seht, wir haben die Größe echt, der Honig-Spray
ist wieder am, am Trollversuche stand, so, den Kram können wir eigentlich wieder rückgängig
machen, brauchen wir ja nicht mal, die Länge können wir auch raus machen, okay, nice, uploaden
wir mal, sehr gut, also das funktioniert wunderbar, übrigens, ich glaube, wir haben es doch nicht
halbiert, wir haben es nur um 20% verringert, weil ich habe das Wlan auch wieder rausgemacht,
das Wlan hatte ich vorher ja auch noch drinne, also, aber wir haben es auf jeden Fall in
der ganzen Ecke verringert, so viel, so viel ist schon mal sicher, gut, das funktioniert
eigentlich, Leute, wollte ich jetzt noch rauskriegen, wie man Batterie auslesen kann, und da habe
ich auf GitHub auch was gefunden, nämlich ESP32MeFlora, genau, das habe ich gefunden
auf GitHub, und der hat ein Beispiel, wie man Batterie ausliest, und da sind wir, wenn
wir das hinkriegen, da sind wir schon mal besser als alle anderen Projekte, die es dazu
gibt, weil es gibt entweder aktive, es gibt Projekte, die aktiv den Sensor querien, alle
paar Sekunden, das verbraucht Batterie erst, fuck, oder Projekte, die rein passiv sind,
und die kriegen keinen Batteriestand, so, was ich jetzt vorhabe zu machen ist, ich lausche
auf den, ich, ich, ich, ich scanne, ich scanne Bluetooth, so lange, bis ich halt die ganzen
Werte von dem Sensor habe, und ich frage einfach einmal alle 5 Stunden den Batteriestand aktiv
ab, und das ist quasi die optimale Kombination aus Energiesparen und Batterielanglebigkeit,
und man hat alle Werte, und besser als alle anderen Projekte, weil das macht sonst keins.
So, wir haben, wir haben ja noch, wir haben noch 10 Minuten Zeit, bis wir das Video gucken,
da basteln wir dann auch schnell was dran rum. Beste Optimierung, ja, sehe ich auch so. So,
damit wir das machen können, was ist da für eine Batterie im Sensor verbaut, so eine Mini-Knopfzelle,
äh, Battery, die Dinge halten aber, sowas kleines, die Dinge halten aber erstaunlich
lange, eine CR203, ich hab ja welche, im, im Hof stehen davon, was ist denn das, wie
viel mAh sind das, ist das 200 oder so, 235, die Dinge halten aber, ich mein 235 mAh
ein paar, das ist nix, das ist einmal, einmal, einmal laut gehusstet, das ist weg, so lauter
Worte, aber, die Dinge halten echt erstaunlich lang, ich hab welche im Hof, also die da
wirklich das machen, wofür sie da sind, nämlich Bodenfeuchtigkeit und so, what the fuck, ich
hab welche im Hof, äh, bei Wind und Wetter, juck dir nicht, der hat ein bisschen Gummi
drin, aber, also, so komplett, komplett tauchticht sind die nicht und die haben über ein Jahr
gehalten, ich weiß es leider nicht, wie lange sie wirklich gehalten haben, weil irgendwann
waren sie weg und ich hab sie nicht ausgetauscht, weil ich sie eh nicht verwendet hab, aber
ich hab über, ich hab, ich hatte über ein Jahr die im Grafana-Dashboard drinne und die
hielten über ein Jahr und danach, keine Ahnung, danach hab ich den Kram ja auch mittlerweile
mal neu installiert, da hab ich die Werte nimmer für, aber die hielten über ein Jahr,
ich sag ja immer, Geräte sollen eigentlich zwei Jahre halten, aber, die Dinger haben
mindestens ein Jahr gehalten und hatten noch ein bisschen Reserve gehabt, also, ich würd
mal sagen, durchaus möglich, dass die eineinhalb Jahre halten, aber nur, wenn man die nicht
aktiv queried, also wenn ich die aktiv querye, per, per Bluetooth, dann ist das Ding wahrscheinlich
nach drei Monaten hinüber, deswegen frag ich die Batterie nur alle fünf Stunden oder
so, ab oder einmal am Tag oder was auch immer, den Rest mach ich hier passiv lauschen, also
sprich, alles was ich hier grad an Werte rein krieg, ist rein passiv, ich frag den Sensor
nicht, der Sensor schickt das alle 30 Sekunden oder so, gibt's nicht den Rechner für, ja
schon, aber du musst wissen, was das Ding verbraucht, dass du rechnen kannst und du
müsstest, du müsstest irgendwie auch den, die Batteriespannung messen können oder du
müsstest die Batteriespannung messen, dann könntest du dir das auch halbwegs ableiten,
aber du kennst nie so genau, wie die Kurve ist dann, ja, ich werd's ja sehen, also,
wir machen jetzt noch mal ganz schnell eine Sache, und zwar, also was ich ja machen will,
ich will noch Batterie querying, wir haben jetzt hier die Frage, wir haben jetzt hier
die Abfrage, dass es diesen Sensor überhaupt gibt, so, und so wie ich mir das jetzt überlegt
habe, machen wir uns einfach eine extra Klasse für so einen Sensor, also eine kleine Flora,
Flora Sensor oder so, so, und dann löschen wir den ganzen Scheiß, weil es C++ ist und
man das alles nicht braucht, und wir könnten auch einen Struct machen, falls wir da keine
einzelnen Methoden für brauchen, und da speichern wir uns ein paar Informationen zu dem Sensor
drin, und dann schreiben wir das alles in einen Array rein, und dann wissen wir welche Sensoren
er schon kennt, und hier in unserer Hauptschleife fragen wir dann den Batteriestand ab alle
fünf Stunden, irgendwie sowas in der Richtung, mal gucken, mal gucken, mal gucken, mal gucken
wie wir das machen, dann bin wir noch nicht, bin wir noch nicht so ganz, ganz schlüssig,
wir brauchen, wir brauchen auf jeden Fall ein paar Infos, wir brauchen, ähm, nennen
wir das mal, keine Ahnung, Light, für, für was, für was ist Lux eigentlich die Einheit?
Für Beleuchtungsstärke, ok, wie heißt das auf Englisch?
Illum, ach du Scheiße, dass ich mir da so ein Wort falsch nicht aussprechen kann, Illuminanz,
Illuminanz, Illuminanz, ach du Krose, ok, Illuminanz, Illuminanz, ach du, das kann ich
halt nochmal aussprechen mit Ansage, Ulum, was, Ulumunanz, Ulumunanz, was, Illuminanz,
Illum, Illuminanz, meine Fresse, was Wörter, äh, ok, Illuminanz nenne ich's, Illuminanz,
excellent, Illuminanz heißt das jetzt, alles klar, Default, Null, es ist schwarz, es ist
dunkel, ähm, dann brauchen wir noch irgendwie Temperature, auch Null, macht man eigentlich
so?
Ne, ne, der ist 10++, da macht man so, ne, oh, Simicolon ans Ende, dann brauchen wir
noch Batteriestand, Batteriestand ist ja was von Null, von Null bis 100, also da reicht
wahrscheinlich so ein Uint, Uint 8 oder sowas, Battery gleich Null, ähm, 5 Stunden sind
18, was zum, 18 Milliarden, was am Millisekunden, das kann schon sein, ja, Illuminanz, so, dann
müssen wir uns noch speichern, wann wir zuletzt die, äh, Last Battery Check oder sowas, da
speichern wir uns die Zeit, wann wir zuletzt abgefragt haben den Batteriestand, weil wir
wollen ja nur alle 5 Stunden oder sowas, äh, Batteriestand abfragen, ohne Spray, wie kommst
du auf 5 Stunden, hab ich, hab ich schon 5 Stunden gesagt vorhin, ich glaub ich hab,
ja doch, ich hab vorhin schon 5 Stunden gesagt, ne, vielleicht mach ich's auch nur einmal
am Tag, so, und dann machen wir noch einen Big Brain Sensor, ähm, Wert für Last Scene,
da schreiben wir rein, wann wir das Gerät das letzte Mal, wann der das letzte Mal das
Gerät gesehen hat, weil es könnte ja sein, dass ein Sensor kaputt geht, wobei ich weiß
gar nicht ob ich den Wert brauch, da kann ich ihn einfach aus dem Home Assistant löschen
und gut ist, ja, mal gucken, so, also jetzt haben wir ein paar unsre Werte, was sagen
die C++ Kenner, sowas als Klasse oder sowas als Trucked, ich so als die Sharp Man mach
eigentlich im Prinzip zu 99% alles als Class, aber man weiß ja nicht, ne, ich lass es übrigens
mal als Klasse, weil ich vielleicht noch ein paar Methoden hinten dran machen, wobei
Strucked, Strucked werden doch immer kopiert, oder, Strucked werden immer kopiert und Class
in Reference, oder, oder ist das ein C, ne, das ist bestimmt ein C++, anders, ich muss
aufhören normaldenkend an C++ dran zu gehen, das ist wahrscheinlich nicht so wie ich mir
das denke, ich lass es jetzt einfach so, so, dann brauchen wir ein Standard weg, ne, oh
wir machen ein big problem, wir nehmen eine Map, und zwar eine Map aus Mac Adresse und
so einem Sensor oder Sensor Instanz, wobei, wenn ich eine Sensor Instanz haben will, brauch
ich nicht sogar einen Pointer dazu, ok, jetzt wird Special C++ Sensors, oh, da bin ich
immer gespannt, ob das jetzt funktioniert, bestimmt nicht, bestimmt nicht, das kann
nicht funktionieren, so, und wir sind schon mal vorausschauend, wir brauchen noch irgendwas,
das, ah ne, hab ich gar nicht included, wir brauchen noch irgendwie das, wir müssen das
locken, weil das C++ Gremium hat sich ja gedacht, es ist keine gute Idee, dass man zumindest
mal Basic, Threadsafe, oder, oder wie auch immer geartete sichere Collections in die
Standard Library baut, das ist nicht, nicht im Sinne des Gremiums gewesen, dementsprechend
muss man sich da selbst drum kümmern, dass man Sachen alles lockt, weil die Sache ist
die, hier schreibe ich, hier schreibe ich Sachen in die, in, in, in das Array rein,
ich weiß, das ist kein Array, ich sag jetzt einfach mal in die Liste rein, und hier unten
werde ich dann parallel drauf zugreifen, das heißt, wenn ich das ändere, während ich
da unten drauf zugreife, gibt's garantiert Probleme, wenn ich das nicht locke, aber tausend
prozentig gibt's dann Probleme, aber wir lassen's, wir können's erstmal weglassen hier, okay,
das heißt, wenn wir diesen Sensor discovered haben das erste Mal, dann schreiben wir ihn,
dann schreiben wir ihn in die Map, by the way, was ist denn so ne Adresse von so nem
Gerät, Advertise, Address, Get Address, was ist das für ein Typ, Nimble Address, vielleicht
machen wir das auch so, vielleicht nehmen wir nicht die Mac Adresse, sondern nehmen
die Adresse von dem Ding, und das bekommt dann auch noch ein Feld dafür, dass ich da
wieder drauf zugreifen kann, so können wir das machen, ja, so, wie schreib ich das jetzt
in meine Map rein, dass das funktioniert, wie geht das, also, also hier hat er das Gerät
erkannt, das heißt, Sensors, Add, ah nee, Sensors, okay, Insert, Insert, Advertised Device,
Address, sowas, und, ja, jetzt brauch ich so nen Sensor, wie, fuck, wie mach ich das in
so, so mach ich das wahrscheinlich nicht, dann ist das irgendein, dann ist das irgendein
allokiertes Objekt, was ich selbst wieder freigeben muss, das wär jetzt die Sharp Style,
das macht man so nicht, wie füg ich denn, wie füg ich denn da jetzt einfach nen Sensor
ein, einfach so, ah, yes, funktioniert das jetzt, natürlich nicht, natürlich nicht,
das wär auch zu einfach, was, Standard Pair, was, jetzt ernsthaft, alter, diese Sprache,
sowas, Standard Pair, und muss ich dann ernsthaft auch noch die Typen nochmal angeben, und das
kann doch nicht denjenigen ernst sein, Make Pair, ah, excellent, viel besser, Make Pair,
viel besser, ja ja, wir haben C++20, das muss hier auch funktionen, ah, jetzt, aber das
ist trotzdem hässlich wie die Nacht, Moment, kann ich nicht, warte mal, ich hab Big, ich
hab Big Brain, Big Brain Idee, doch, eventuell kannst du Auto hinschreiben, ich hab ne Idee,
ich hab ne Idee, warte mal, geht das, das geht auch, ok, warum kann der hier für mich
nen Pair Maken und bei dem Insert nicht, ich versuch das gar nicht zu verstehen, ok, jetzt
hab ich den, jetzt hab ich den Sensor hier drin, ja aber wie schreib ich denn jetzt was
in den Sensor rein, eigentlich müsste ich jetzt so wahrscheinlich sowas hier machen,
Sensor, so, aber, aber jetzt ist der Sensor, aber jetzt ist der Sensor in der Map nicht
der Sensor, oder, das funktioniert doch jetzt bestimmt nicht, der wird kopiert beim Assign,
ja, das ist ja kacke, das will ich ja net, guck mal, wenn ich jetzt sowas hier mache,
äh, Address, ah, irgendwie mal, ja, Adre, ich fang jetzt auch schon an mit so komischen
C++ Abkürzung, Adre, ähm, dann funktioniert das net, dann mach Pointer, ich hab nen C++
Vortrag gesehen, ihr werdet's mir nicht glauben, aber ich hab nen, ich hab nen Vortrag gesehen
von einem aus dem C++-Cremium und der hat Wortwörter, das war ja schon, das war schon ein Fehler,
ich weiß, aber, ähm, der hat ernsthaft gesagt in diesem Vortrag, und da halt ich mich jetzt
dran, never use raw pointers, mit C++ neuer als 14 oder so, wie das funktioniert oder
was, ernsthaft, it's, das wird immer schlimmer, man könnte so nen, man könnte so nen shared,
shared pointer oder sowas nehmen, ey, das muss doch anders funktionieren, das muss doch,
das muss doch anders funktionieren, die haben doch, die haben doch, guck mal, die haben doch
mit so nem Zeug angefangen wie standard move und sowas, wo man, wo man da das hin und her
schieben kann, das kann doch nicht sein, das kann doch nicht sein, das ist, ok, ok, pass
mal auf, alter, Corona, stell's, wir machen jetzt massive brain, massive brain, wir testen
erstmal, ob das überhaupt so ist, wie wir uns das denken, dass es nicht funktioniert,
ok, also hier, wenn er das erkennt, wenn er das erkennt, edit er das, und schreibt die
Adresse rein, also, das heißt wir kommentieren einfach mal alles aus, und das einzige, was
wir übrig lassen, ist nen Print von der Adresse, adre1, wir machen dann nämlich gleich noch
ein Debug, beides mal anders, so, so, das gibt die Adresse aus, und nun gehen wir in
unsere Schleife hier unten, und Sensors gehen einmal durch alle Sensors durch, gibt's, weiß
jemand, ob's ne schöne, ob's ne schöne, ein schönes Konstrukt gibt, hier vorne jetzt
Key-Value-Pairs raus zu holen, also quasi sowas hier, Adress-Value oder so, geht das
vielleicht?
Nee, da funktioniert das, da gibt's bestimmt irgendwas für, ah, mit, mit, mit, aha, ok,
warum auch was nehmen, was man, was man schon gewöhnt ist, aber wenn ich das jetzt richtig
verstehe, jetzt ist die Frage, was, was macht der da eigentlich jetzt, kopiert er mir jetzt
bei jedem Durchlauf die Werte da rein, oder ist das ne Referenz auf die Werte aus dem,
aus der Map, also ist, ist das hier jetzt, also ist das hier jetzt mein Flora-Sensor
von da oben, oder ist das ne neuer kopierter, man weiß es nicht, man weiß es nicht, ähm,
wenn wir ja gleich sehen, gebt mal die, das ist ne gute Idee, ich wollte das von hier
oben kopieren, also, ähm, wenn das so ist, wie ich mir das denke, dass das nicht funktioniert,
dann passiert jetzt folgendes, ich schreib hier den Sensor rein, da ist, das hier ist
noch, ähm, ich nehm mal was anderes, ich nehm mal Batterie oder so, Sensor, Battery
gleich 100, machen wir jetzt einfach, so, wenn das jetzt so funktioniert, dann ist Batterie,
obwohl ich hier 100 reinschreibe, hier unten, wieder 0, excellent Printline Debugging, so
muss das sein, so machen das die Profis auch, so, ok, hier oben kommt raus, Sensor, Battery
100 und da unten kommt 0 raus, wenn das so funktioniert, wie ich mir das vorstelle,
was, wo soll ich breaken, da, da ist doch nix drin, oder, da ist doch, da ist doch maximal
ein Sensor drin, oh, das ist kaputt, guckt, das ist genauso, wie ich gesagt hab, Battery
1, 100, Battery, ok, ok, 4, Range, C++, Reference, Vector, wir fragen jetzt Dagger Overflow,
Get Item by Value a Reference, ok, zeig ich her, und, man muss ein und davor machen, ja,
ich weiß, aber Vector und Map wirds gleiche sein, Vector wird öfters verwendet, ok, choose
Auto x, when you want to work with Copies, choose Auto und x, when you want to work with
Original Item and may modifies, choose Auto Const, choose Auto Const x, when you want,
it will not modify, ok, ich muss sagen, Saito, ich geb dir Recht, irgendwo machts Sinn, irgendwo
machts schon Sinn, ja, aber ich find die Sintax wieder so unglaublich eklig, warum,
by the way, wenn das jetzt ne Reference ist, warum kann ich da nen, hm, warum kann ich
da nen Punkt verwenden, ich dachte ne Reference ist quasi nen Pointer und nen Pointer macht
das da, warum kann ich da jetzt mit nem Punkt drauf zugreifen, obwohl es ne Reference ist,
kann mir das einer erklären, jetzt mal ernsthaft gemeint, also, das heißt, es ist noch nicht
mal einheitlich, dass man auf ne Reference mit nem Pfeil zugreift, puh, ein Reference
ist kein Punkt, Reference ist ein Pfeil, wie, so wie da, guck, das ist nen Pointer, das
ist nen Pfeil, so, aber warum ist, warum ist hier, die Reference, also, erstens, warum
ist ne Reference was anderes wie nen Pointer und warum ist die Reference und der Pointer
nicht die Sintax einheitlich, das verwirrt mich unglaublich, diese Sprache immer, ich
mein, die Sintax ist ok, die versteh ich, die leuchtet ein, aber das, danach wieder,
ok, das heißt, jetzt greif ich auf das richtige Element zu, das funktioniert aber immer noch
nicht, das funktioniert aber immer noch nicht, weil hier greif ich nicht auf das Element
zu, wie, was ich da reinschreibe, wie krieg ich das jetzt hin, genau, wie krieg ich das
jetzt hin, dass der Sensor hier auch ne Reference ist, nämlich ne Reference auf das, was in
der Map ist, so, das Dumme ist, ich kanns nicht in die Map schreiben, bevor ich den Sensor
hab und ich kann mir keine Reference aus der Map holen, wenn ich den Sensor, äh, das,
das beißt sich, wie geht das jetzt, kann ich, ok, jetzt mal was ganz abgedrehtes, ist
dann prinzipiell sowas hier ne gültige Sintax, ist dann sowas wenigstens ne gültige Sintax,
so potentiell zumindest, ne, moment, what, aber das crash jetzt bestimmt, weil, weil
das gibt's ja noch net, ne, jetzt ist ja das crash, das gibt's, hä, das geht, warum im
alles in der Welt geht das, das gibt's doch gar nicht an der Stelle, wa, hä, ok, ich,
ich predikte mal was passiert, wenn man auf ein Element zugreift, was es nicht gibt, erzeugt
es ein Default Element für ein und das möchte ich als Reference haben, also, der Vektor
beziehungsweise die Map ist so schlau, wenn ich sie frage, gib mir ein Element, was es
nicht gibt, dann gibts mir nen Default Element davon zurück, boah, ist das Magic, das gefällt
mir überhaupt nicht, so, das heißt aber auch, haha, das heißt aber auch, wenn ich mein Constructor
Private mache, dann geht das nicht mehr, warte mal, das muss ich jetzt ausprobieren,
so, Private Constructor, jetzt geht es nicht mehr, oder, schreckt, ok, dann ergibt es
wenigstens nen Sinnwas, Moment, wo, wo ist es denn überhaupt kaputt, ah, yes, C++-Fehlermeldung,
excellent, excellent, alles klar, ah, is in Private Context, nein, ich glaube nicht an
der Stelle, lieber auf Rust wechseln, ok, ok, verstehe, verstehe, verstehe, Leute, ich
hab ne Idee, ich glaube, Private Constructor, warum sollte das überhaupt gehen, na das hat
schon seinen Sinn, zum Beispiel, wenn du das über ne Factory Methode machen willst oder
irgendwelche Singleton Geschichten oder so, na also wenn du zum Beispiel ne extra Klasse
hast, die diese Klasse instanziert, dann könnte man das machen, oder wenn du willst, dass
man nur einmal ne Klasse instanzieren kann, einmalig, dann musst du nen Private Constructor
machen und ne Construct Methode, es hat nicht so oft Sinn, aber das kann schon Sinn machen,
ja, Sinn ergeben, so, wie würd ich denn, ok, mal angenommen, ich hätte jetzt nen Private
Constructor, nur mal theoretisch, dass ich das jetzt verstehe, was hier überhaupt passiert,
könnte ich jetzt, jetzt machen wir mal richtig Big Brain, Big Brain Taktik, könnte ich hier
sowas machen, das da, gleich, was macht der denn, wenn es das schon gibt, wisst ihr was,
Scheiß drauf, ich lass es einfach so, ich lass es einfach so, ich find es zwar äußerst
unschön, ehrlich gesagt, aber es funktioniert, das Rest ist mir egal, wobei Factories halt
auch nicht funktionieren, sag mal so, nicht so richtig, in anderen Sprachen gescheit
funktionieren, in C++ geht das, weil du kannst in C++ der anderen Klasse Zugriff auf deine
Private Methoden geben, das geht beispielsweise in C Sharp nicht, in C Sharp kannst du keine
Factory machen, die nen Private Constructor aufruft, das funktioniert nicht, du kannst
das höchstens in ein eigenes Assembly packen und dann internal verwenden, das geht, deswegen
macht man das da nicht so gerne, deswegen macht man da eher in der eigenen Klasse ne
Static Construct Methode oder irgendein Builder oder sowas, so, das funktioniert, ich hab
legit keine Ahnung, was sie sich dabei gedacht haben, warum das, aber gut, Magic, es funktioniert,
alles klar, das ist doch abgedreht, das soll ne Exception werfen hier, oder abkacken, warum
gibt es denn Default Objekte zurück, das ergibt überhaupt keinen Sinn, das ist überhaupt
nicht die Aufgabe von einer Collection nen Standardobjekt für mich zu bauen unter der
Haube, das ist kacke, laut Doku sollte es eigentlich ne Exception fliegen, ja wahrscheinlich
wenn ich sag Get und nicht wenn ich hier drauf zugreife über diese Array, ich plicks nicht,
es macht aber auch nix, es macht aber auch nix, man muss das nicht verstehen, das Cremium
wirds wahrscheinlich verstehen, vor allem kann das auch gegebenenfalls, ja Cooper ich sehe
das genauso, ich verstehe, ich finde es überhaupt nicht gut, wenn es dir eher gefällt kannst
du den Copy Constructor schreiben, ja aber ich lass das jetzt einfach so, bekommst du
eventuell nen Pointer auf unizialisierten Speichern, ne bekomm ich nicht, weil ich kann
da Sachen reinschreiben und die sind danach noch da und es crasht auch nicht und es funktioniert,
es funktioniert einfach, ok Big Brain, Big Brain Time vorbei, gut, ok Leute genug, genug
Big Brain Time für heute, wir gucken uns jetzt noch das Semper Video an, ich weiß wir haben
auch nicht so viel Progress gemacht, mehr gelabert, aber muss ja auch mal sein, also
was soll ich mir angucken, das da, Telekom Vodafone haben jetzt ein Filternet, der Wupploos,
kommst du da drauf, wie kommst du, hätt ich jetzt nicht gedacht, so, hast du schon mal
voll nen Code gesehen, ja das kenn ich das Video, das kenn ich, das kenn ich, das kenn
ich, aber auf die Frage hin, hast du schon mal, hast du schon mal, also das Video kenn
ich, das ist wirklich cool, wo sie super Magic machen in der Quake Engine, aber ich hab
mal ne Frage an euch, was was ihr garantiert noch nicht gesehen habt, habt ihr schon mal
Spieler auf Stadia gesehen, nope Mythos, ja, ok gucken wir uns das Semper Video jetzt noch
zum Schluss an, also Telekom und Vodafone, ich mag das ja, wie er die Wörter ausspricht,
der sagt ja sowas wie, die Provider, ich kann das nicht nachmachen, man kann Semper
sehen, das ist unglaublich schlecht da man, die Provider, sagt der, der sagt ja die Provider,
sagt der Provider, Vodafone und die Provider, ich kann, kann man echt zau-mäßig schwer
nachmachen, aber man erkennt ihn sofort, die Provider haben jetzt ein Filternet, irgendwie
sowas in der Richtung, Windows 10, genau, sowas in der, ja genau, huge joke, aber ich guck
die Sachen ab und zu echt gerne, natürlich nicht, und die sagen ja auch, das eine hat
mit dem anderen gar nichts zu tun, geh ich mal von ab, noch lauter, ja, das ist nichts
Neues, ja, und man könnte jetzt eigentlich argumentieren, das reicht doch, und ich denke
mal, das macht er auch, die Provider haben die ganze Zeit gesagt, wir sind die Guten,
wir sperren nichts, wir machen nichts, freies Internet, blablabla, aber dass sowas nicht
lange hält, war ja davon auszugehen, ich gehe, ich gehe ins Internets, wenn schon,
wir wissen ja auch, dass man im Internets nicht surft, sondern, oh, wie haben die das
auf diesen super christlichen Seiten früher immer geschrieben, man surft, man, man Internets
surft nicht, man, wie hieß das, ich, genau, ich Internets stehsegle, ich weiß, ist Paints
Champ, aber kennt ihr diese komischen Seiten noch, die, die, die so versucht haben, so
auf Fake christlich zu machen, da gab es doch Arsche, Arsche, wie hießen die denn, die
dann auch alles deutsch, keine Anglizismen geschrieben haben, Arsche, Internets, waren
die das, ja, genau, die, wo man, wo damals Leute wirklich geglaubt haben, das ist echt,
ja, das sind so Seiten, die so auf super christlich gemacht sind und keine Anglizismen verwenden,
so, das ist aber, das ist aber halt ein Witz, und viele Leute haben das damals nicht, nicht
gecheckt, heutzutage würde ich sagen, hey, das könnte auch genauso gut kein Witz sein,
man weiß ja nicht so genau, aber das war auf jeden Fall ein Witz, du warst mit 13 Jahren
im Video, nice, ja, by the way, das finde ich auch vollkommen okay, das finde ich auch
vollkommen okay, warum sollte der Provider haften, wenn du Scheiße baust, sollst gefälligst
du haften.
Manipuliert oder kontrolliert, und so ähnlich ist das auch bei der Post, die schaut nämlich
auch nicht in die Pakete oder in die Briefe rein, sondern die liefert die einfach nur
aus, und im Grunde lief das so bis, naja, mehr oder weniger heute, aber Recht zu haben
und Recht zu bekommen war für einen Teil der Urheber offenbar nicht gut genug, was
für ein Blödsinn, dass man aber auch erst die Gerichte fragen muss, außer man ist ein
RedTube-Abmahn-Anwalt, da muss man auch die Gerichte fragen, aber die winken es dann
einfach durch, und sind nicht glücklich drüber, warum denn auf dumme Gesetze hören, auf jeden
Fall haben sich jetzt einige der Urheber zusammengeschlossen und entschieden, dass das Internet in der
Form, wie es derzeit existiert, nicht gut für uns ist oder für sie, es muss gesäubert
werden, deswegen braucht es eine Clearing-Stelle im Internet, und die muss jetzt das Internet
reinigen, findet man unter kui.info, und da findet man unter anderem auch die Mitglieder,
die sich da zusammengeschlossen haben, also habe ich jemanden aufgerufen und dann hier
auf Mitglieder geklickt, und dann sieht man hier nach oben.
Ich weiß nicht, Piek, macht die Post das erst auf, also muss dann einer von der Polizei
kommen und macht das auf, oder braucht der irgendeine Anordnung dazu, oder aber ist die
Post, die Post wird da zumindest beauftragt sein dazu, das zu tun.
So nach dem Motto, da gibt es irgendwelche Auflagen, Post muss sicherstellen, das, blablabla,
oder.
Wenn ich es an die Polizei weitergeben, finde ich das vollkommen in Ordnung.
Es rollt eben, also Mitglieder in dem Verein, dieser Clearing-Stelle ist eben 1&1 als Provider,
ja E-Books, Musik, MP3, Fußball, Bundesliga, Spiele, noch ein Provider, Filme, schlechte
Filme, die Schwesterorganisation der DTL, keine Ahnung, ach Moment, VGF ist die Frankfurter
Verkehrsgesellschaft, ne VFG, ich dachte, was hat die Straßenbahn in Frankfurt damit zu tun.
Das ist Telefonica Provider, Telekom Provider, Vodafone Provider, Filmverband, Verband der
Filmverleiher, warum die überhaupt Verleiher heißen, Verleiher ist kostenlos laut dem BGB,
außerdem kriegt man das Teil zurück, was man verliehen hat, naja egal, also deswegen,
die haben sich dazu entschieden, festzustellen für sie, was denn geklärt werden muss, und
da gibt es eben jetzt Webseiten im Internet, auf die kann man nicht mehr zugreifen, jetzt
einfach mal hier gezeigt, ich greife jetzt mal auf s.to zu, also s.to, und wenn ich da
drauf klicke, dann werde ich direkt reitegeleitet an notice.cui.info, und da steht dann eben,
die Webseite ist jetzt nicht mehr verfügbar.
Das heißt, theoretisch einfach DNS umstellen und gut ist.
Jetzt geht es jetzt um Webseiten, die Urheberrechte der Mitglieder verletzen, und da kann man
jetzt natürlich Sympathien zeigen, von wegen ja okay, aber es sind ja Urheberrechtsverletzungen,
ja richtig, kann man, aber es gibt natürlich einen Grund, warum eigentlich nur der Staat
entscheiden soll, was wann gesperrt wird und wann eben nicht, weil das eben zum Beispiel
vorher eben die entsprechenden Gerichte durchlaufen hat und dann am Ende ein Richter entscheidet,
da haben wir uns eigentlich drauf, ich sag mal verständigt.
Die Gerichte haben saumäßig viel zu tun, ja, die haben da keinen Bock drauf, aber ja,
das sehe ich auch so, im Endeffekt sollte das eher ein Gericht entscheiden, und dadurch,
dass unsere Gerichte so überlastet sind, kommt so Geschiss zusammen, wie die RedTube-Abmahn-Typen,
die, wo das dann einfach durchgewunken wird, aber als die gemerkt haben, die haben sie
beschissen, das fanden die Richter nicht so geil, ich glaube der Typ hat danach auch seine
Lizenz verloren, die RedTube-Leute.
Also ich bin, wie gesagt, ich bin der Meinung, ein Provider sollte dafür sorgen, dass man
möglichst ungehindert, unabhängig von irgendwelchen Interessen ins Internet kommt, ein Provider
sollte in erster Linie dafür sorgen, dass man einen guten Zugang hat, ja, zu allem.
Wenn dann entschieden wird, dass was wirklich belehrt, also quasi entschieden, Gericht
entschieden wurde, das was illegal ist, ja, dass man dann die Provider dazu verpflichtet,
das zu blocken, okay, aber irgendwelche Zusammenschlüsse hier finde ich total daneben.
Privatverbund.
Weil ich meine, letztendlich, die können danach gut dünken entscheiden, was mal lustig
ist, sagen jetzt, wir haben es ja vorhin gelesen, es gibt irgendeinen Creme, das muss nur ein,
das muss einstimmig entschieden werden, blablabla, aber man muss sich doch mal angucken, wer
da drin steht, die entscheiden das schon einstimmig.
Ja, das Sollmerke-Video können wir uns jetzt leider nicht mal angucken, ist schon ein
bisschen spät.
... und entscheidet nach eigenem Dafürhalten, wann eine Seite geklärt werden muss, das wirft
natürlich eine Melia-Frage.
Clearing-Stelle, hört sich aber auch so sauber an, ne?
Zum Beispiel, es geht denen gar nicht darum, Urheberrechtsverletzungen zu verhindern, es
geht denen nur darum, die Urheberrechtsverletzungen der eigenen Mitglieder zu verhindern, das
von anderen Urheberrechten ebenfalls verletzt...
Hat jemand, hat einer mal das Video zu, zu, zu, zum Anwalt, vielleicht ist es ja nicht
so lang.
... werden auf anderen Webseiten, das der Telekom und den anderen Providern völlig egal,
aber sobald von einem Mitglied ein Recht verletzt wird, ja, dann sperren wir das für alle im
Internet.
Nächste Frage, Vera.
Ist ja zum Glück nicht.
Wann ist eine Seite Urheberrechtsverletzungen, für die Prozentverletzungen muss dabei sein?
Sind demnächst auch die Seiten verletzend, die zeigen, wie man drum herumkommt?
Ja, ja, damit, damit ist zu rechnen, ja, das sagen sie jetzt erstmal nicht, aber Salami-Taktik
sind die Meister drin.
... S-Server unter Windows zu wechseln, denn, und das ist ja der wichtige Teil, es geht
nicht darum, dass die Klientel dieser Webseiten sowieso weiß, wie man um die Sperren drum
herumkommt, das weiß ich ja auch, wenn ich nur Videos machen würde zu den Themen, um
die ich nicht drum herumkomme, dann wären da gerade mal zwei Videos, insoweit es geht
darum, dass das grundsätzlich höchst fraglich ist, es geht darum, dass, wenn das Modell...
Mit Salami-Taktik meine ich natürlich, was Scheibchenweise durchsetzt und nicht Salami,
ja.
Da muss man jetzt kein Quartabitur haben, um sich auszurechnen, was die sich denn als
nächstes fragen, was gut wäre für uns, also was man sperren sollte, scheint sich ja keiner
drüber aufzuregen.
Nächste Frage wäre, wie eben schon erwähnt, der Gesetzgeber hat die Provider bisher immer
geschützt, weil die halt nur durchleitender waren, das heißt, die hatten nie Probleme,
insoweit fragt man sich, warum machen die sowas mit, wie viele Millionen müssen da
geflossen sein, damit die sich freiwillig aufs Sperren einlassen?
Ich meine, die letzten 25 Jahre im Internet hat es auch keinen da interessiert, die haben
sich sogar regelmäßig dagegen gewehrt, Sperren umsetzen zu müssen.
Richtig.
Und auf einmal machen die das Ganze freiwillig, kann da jetzt jeder mit seinem Geld einfach
vorbeikommen und Sperren kaufen, sich das Internet so zurechtstutzen, wie es ihm gefällt
und die machen einfach alles mit, kommt da demnächst der Verband...
Ja, warum die Provider da jetzt auf einmal so scharf drauf sind, verstehe ich auch nicht
so ganz, liegt wahrscheinlich daran, erstens durch gute Lobbyarbeit der Typen da und dass
Provider mittlerweile auch zu einem großen Teil Content-Anbieter geworden sind, darf
man ja nicht vergessen, ja, wurde davon offensichtlich, die Telekom mittlerweile auch...
...Kleeringsstelle, also CCS, und will alles sperren, was nicht christlich ist und machen
die das dann auch, oder schlimmer noch, die LCS, also die löbliche Clearingstelle, die
alle Webseiten sperrt, die nicht löblich sind, also ich sag mal, meine Kollegen...
...Wir sind besorgt.
Vor allem, wie ebenfalls schon erwähnt, weil das Provider-Privileg eigentlich immer nur
gilt, wenn der Provider die Daten selbst nur weiterleitet und eben nicht Block-Wart spielt
und selber entscheidet, welche Anfragen umgewogen werden...
By the way, jemand der geschrieben hat, du bekommst eine HTTPS-Nachricht, das kann nur
so lange funktionieren, wie das sich dein Browser irgendwie gemerkt hat, weil ansonsten
solltest du da keine HTTPS-Nachricht kriegen, du machst eine DNS-Auflösung und bei einer
DNS-Auflösung kommt raus, komische seite.de hat eine andere IP und die hat dann selbstverständlich
ein gültiges Zertifikat für Zeug oder so, keine Ahnung, das könnte durchaus passen,
wobei, nee, das geht nicht.
Nein, ich hab Mist erzählt, das geht nicht, weil der Browser das checkt.
Das geht eigentlich nicht, stimmt.
Theoretisch, Moment.
Genau, die haben kein gültiges Zertifikat, das heißt, wenn du auf HTTPS, sagen wir mal
so, mal angenommen, die würden Google blocken und du gehst auf HTTPS-Google.de, die würden
das umleiten auf eine andere IP, die haben kein gültiges Zertifikat für Google, nee,
brauchst du, das müsste ich mir mal überlegen, weil du kannst eigentlich nicht weiterleiten
über HTTPS, wenn du das Ursprungszertifikat nicht hast.
Da müssen wir mal Gedanken drüber machen, ob das geht oder ob das nicht geht.
Ja, weil ein Zertifikat für die Zusatzseite haben die nicht.
Aber selbst mit einem CNAME, ist doch eigentlich egal.
Das sollte doch eigentlich nicht funktionieren, oder?
Jetzt müssen wir mal Gedanken drüber machen.
Ich meine, bei einem CNAME sagst du ja im Endeffekt, nur diese Domain ist auch noch
unter was anderem erreichbar.
So.
Aber dann deine Browser anfangen, gta, explizit, dann HTTPS, Google.de zum Beispiel, und selbst
wenn dann DNS sagt, das ist noch woanders verfügbar, das müsste der Browser eigentlich
checken.
Ich bleibe schon mal Gedanken drüber machen, das ist nicht so einfach.
Ja, stimmt, ich erinnere mich, ich erinnere mich, ja, ich erinnere mich, ja, ich erinnere
mich.
Ja, das ist angesprochen, ganz contextuell genau, das ist ist das Schwein, der dann auch
Legale Privatkopien zu verschaffen oder runter zu laden ja und das geht natürlich nicht dass sie an ihr recht kommen
Deswegen musste das ganze gesperrt werden und so weiter und so fort wie gesagt
Videos behandelt denn es geht ja nicht um ihr recht es geht um ihr geld und das soll nicht bei ihnen bleiben sondern bei denen deswegen
Hashtag Filternet und Hashtag Change your DNS
Ja, wie genau zeigen wir in einem anderen video beziehungsweise haben wir
Ich möchte mit euch mal ein experiment vor 13 minuten ganz böse seite im internet auf und diese
geht es nicht lautet
serien stream punkt es ist was seht ihr hier
Es funktioniert nicht seitens aus urheberrechtlichen gründen
Nicht was lustig ist durch diese ganze geschichten kriegen mehr leute die seiten jetzt gezeigt in videos die nicht funktionieren
zu den hintergründen
informieren sie sich bitte hier
clearing stelle urheberrecht im
internet also geben wir drauf und dann über uns die clearing stelle ueberrecht im internet
Wollt ihr das kann das dauert so lange ich muss jetzt ins bett pennen macht es gut ich kann mir das jetzt nicht noch angucken
Ich muss mir muss man ein bisschen gedanken machen über die dns geschichte
Ihr vielleicht wirft auch nur ein fehler bei euch weil ich schon mal auf der seite wart vorher ich bin mir da echt nicht sicher
was man da machen kann und was nicht
Also alles klar leute bis denn macht es gut co